the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to day one of the 2023
American Cup held at the Saint Louis
chess club we started the in the World
Chess Hall of Fame as we are waiting for
the players to arrive it's going to be a
couple of weeks of exciting fantastic
chess let's go to the studio and start
the action with Yasser and Joe
we welcome you to St Louis Missouri the
capital of Chess in America this is day
one of the 2023 American cup from the
Saint Louis chess club
foreign
[Music]
chess club Studio I'm Ivanka houska and
it is a great pleasure to be here
calling the action in one of the most
amazing tournaments around with the one
and only Grandmaster yasa sarawan you
stole my introduction Yogi welcome
welcome to St Louis it's lovely to have
you here thank you absolutely hello
everyone and welcome to the chess season
it gets started with the American Cup
this is our second event of the American
Cup a double elimination Double match
elimination event and Fabi our defending
champion won the first event with one
second on his clock in one particular
match but as we get to it tell us the
roster for the open players oh my get
ready to be impressed because take a
look at this WOW topping the roster is
Hikaru Nakamura one of the world's
strongest players and following him is
another Elite player Fabiana caruana
Wesley so Lavon aronian and if that's
not enough we have a whole bunch of 2700
following these guys I mean this is
insane remarkably strong open and in the
ladies yep and uh topping the bill here
is none other than American Legend Grand
Master Arena Crush now she was last
year's tournament winner she raced away
with the title but she's closely
followed by Alice Lee who get this is
only 13 years old has two International
Master Norms to her name as well as
several wins against top players
absolutely and again look at the Anna
begum Katrina Naji a Tusa she's a
newcomer to American chess yes she is
but she's been around for quite a while
she's very experienced she's been seven
time Iranian Women's Champion so a lot
of titles to her name and she's followed
by a very experienced veteran tattoo
Tanya welcome welcome to everybody and
our format uh Joey yeah I mean this is
so exciting it's thrilling like no other
it is a 2-8 player double elimination
bracket tournament double elimination
basically means that if you lose a match
that's okay you drop down to the
elimination bracket there are no draw
offers whatsoever and if you're playing
in the Champions bracket then you play
at the classical time control of 90
minutes plus 30 second increment please
note there is no added time after move
40 but if you do lose a match this is
where things really heat up because you
drop down to the elimination bracket
where you're playing rapid chess right
25 minutes plus 10 second increment and
take a look at this price fund 200
000 for the open 100 000 for the ladies
this is a very very handsome price point
indeed and our schedule Jovi yes there's
a lot a lot of action on her head and
today everyone starts off
playing one classical game today and
another classical game tomorrow and the
same with the women's section tomorrow
though if the matches are tied we do see
playoffs and you know tie breaks and
maybe even the best of all Armageddon
it's exciting and we're very thrilled to
have in studio with this Christian
Christiana as first of all good to see
you my friend it's it's been a while
good to see you guys good to see you
back in a St Louis Jovi it's uh great to
be back in the commentary booth and we
have so much exciting action coming your
way this is one of my favorite events
last year we were doing commentary and
you were mentioning one particular match
Yasser at the beginning of the show that
match between caruana and Jeffrey strong
that went all the way into the
Armageddon and unfortunately for Jeffrey
he was just too slow with his peace
movement that would have taken carwana
to the elimination station bracket he
didn't go to the elimination bracket he
won that and he actually did not drop a
single game all the way until the title
well let's take a look at the brackets
right now and see what we have in store
well in the open section we have Hikaru
Nakamura who is coming into this event
as the rating favorite he will be facing
Sam Savion who is I have to say an
expert in shorter time controls aronian
vs Dominguez Wesley saw versus Sam
Shanklin and the defending Champion
Fabiano caruana against Ray Robson and
let's take a look at what we have in the
ladies section as well we have Irina
Crush who had an amazing event last year
the defending Champion did not drop a
single game as well and she will be
facing
versus named Silva zatonski vs paikidze
and Alice Lee only 13 years of age she's
been having an incredible year she she's
been carrying her Pro chess League team
the Saint Louis Archbishop to the
playoffs and she will be facing
porcasian the newcomer into the event
guys we have so much amazing chess in
all different time formats coming your
way absolutely thanks for that I didn't
know that Alice was carrying the water
for the St Louis chess team as we get a
look at the World Chess Hall of Fame who
is hosting the players and we see Sam
Savion getting Sam Sevilla Sam Shanklin
getting wandered as they come into the
playing Hall
one of the exhibition halls and they've
made it into a playing horns here we can
see the players getting ready they all
have their pre-tournament pre-game
rituals received Ray Robson
and as I think I saw in the corner as
well
she loves to arrive early and get into
the Zone exactly there we see Lanier
Dominguez and he was wearing a
Letterman's jacket that was one of the
uh at the opening ceremony we've got
some footage of the opening ceremony
that we'll be sharing with you later
where they get these Letterman's jackets
for the ladies and uh last year's
champion and uh here we have the Fabiana
caruana who had a very eventful ride he
did to the top I remember watching that
live you know seeing him survive but
there's seconds left on the clock and uh
also we saw Arena crash who had white
contrast a very smooth part she did
indeed and she defeated Alice Lee who's
turning out to be at a number two seed
will be seeing a rematch who knows that
anyway yesterday at the opening ceremony
I just said that they had the
Letterman's jacket when he was wearing
there you see a two shot
she is and she is definitely an unknown
kind of element to all the other players
but very very experienced and uh there
we see her getting ready to face off
against none other than Alice Lee Yes
play to her Advantage the fact that
these players don't know her as well
they haven't played against her as many
times as they have played each other so
she can definitely bring that element of
surprise to her games Christian did you
like arriving early or were you one of
the late arrivals too I'm always the
late arrival oh always I lay the rivals
sometimes I'm like five minutes late
nowadays a bit more difficult to do that
because you have all these uh security
process and that you have to go through
so it's a completely different system
but back in the days when and I'm also
not as active recently uh but back in
the days I always like to make my own
Wait For Me Maybe that's maybe that's a
bad thing I don't know Jeremy how about
you
were you an early or late arrival I'm
normally late arrival but that's not for
any psychological reasons simply because
I'm just late in general but I mean
there's something to be said with
Christian's philosophy because you know
yours when you shake hands and you're
standing up your opponent's sitting down
that's a good point that's right I like
it no uh so are you guys out you got me
two to one I love being early I love
getting my score sheet properly uh
getting the Zen of the of the playing
Hall
I'm sensitive to the noises I I have
very very good hearing in fact and so I
wanna I wanna know what noises to be
discounting and look out for uh if the
floor itself you know somebody comes
over and watches your games
like that I guess we're hearing some
opening announcements by Chris Berlin
[Music]
you keep score move after move
um
the cowbell as she's getting ready to
ring in the first round make sure
in any draw plans we'll verify that
claim and then we'll get you on your way
this is game one
of a two-game match
you will play the same opponent tomorrow
but just with the colors reversed thank
you to those of you who are here on time
to allow us to get through the security
checks
Etc
restroom and Italians okay
restroom is around the corner here there
is one restroom for all the players so
one restroom that's all we have access
to
um and there are Refreshments where
they're just past the restroom if you
need refreshments and there's actually a
lounge area that you can access as well
and we've checked that area so you
there's a lounge access and you can see
the dgt display in the other room if you
want to just hang out in there and see
when your product makes the next move
anybody have any questions
[Applause]
one comment bathroom okay we are now
one minute lit sorry about that uh on
the Bell good luck everybody please go
ahead and start White's block
oh
they are off and uh players getting
ready to make their first move and we
see Hikaru starts off with E4 exactly
and an interesting thing about Sam is
that this is not the first game that
he's played today he was actually
playing in the Pro chess league and last
time when I saw it he had the one one
game and lost two how did he do in the
fourth game I have I have to say I did
not watch uh that match uh I I do know
there were discussions that he's going
to be playing the protest league and we
weren't sure whether he's actually going
to make it to uh at the beginning of the
first round but uh obviously he made it
it's just right here and he's going to
have to defend against a very tough
opponent Hikaru who is definitely in an
aggressive mood it seems like e45 Knight
F3 let's see how he follows up uh the
rui Lopez maybe the Italian with Bishop
C4 let's see what the scotch uh it was
actually funny at the opening ceremony
yesterday it was actually the players
meeting and as the Arbiter Chris bird
was inviting all the players
Hikaru says well when can I claim a
forfeit I was like what so it's like if
my opponent's late when do how long do I
have to wait well you have to wait 30
minutes before the forfeit but why do
you ask well Sam's playing pro league
tomorrow and he may be late for the
games man I'm not going to be late
exactly it was pretty funny I mean it is
with Carl it does essay the uh Lopez I
was going to say I mean every tournament
these days
should have a Berlin but it's not going
to be in this particular game as a7a6
Bishop A4 very quickly on the board
um I see uh this matchup by the way as
really a great one because to my mind
Hikaru is a generational player where
Blitz and Rapid are concerned like he
just is extraordinarily good and for Sam
Sam fancies himself too in uh especially
I want to say Rapids uh so this is a
match if it does Go the Distance it's
going to be a fun one to call I I mean I
I do think Hikaru is a favorite but not
by much not by Macho let's not forget
Sam was in the top 16 in the global
Chess Championship last year so he's
definitely one of the top elite players
in the world when it comes to those
short time controls and I want to
remember that match between him and
Fabiano
in last year's American Cup that one
went haywire into uh those rapid
playoffs and I have to say I think he
was with the black pieces you know crazy
Sicilian winning at some point so he had
his chances he will have his chances in
this matchup as well d2d3 a modest move
uh
in the rui Lopez like everybody who's
been playing castles and you go from
here you can play the open uh Spanish
with Knight takes E4 but uh d2d3 side
steps the open Spanish but it does so at
the cost of the fact that you want to
play C3 and D4 and you've played D3 at
first I've always felt that after B5
Bishop B3 Bishop C5 which is very very
standard book uh kind of a classical if
you will where white is already
committed himself to D3 I don't see this
is getting much of an advantage for
white but we'll see
by the way Ray who loves his Olympic
team jacket it's like his his lucky
jacket it's this blue uh jacket you know
he's not he's not wearing it today so
this is a unusual hooray let's just jump
around the board around the hall and
we'll pick up the game between Levon
oronian and Lanier as their essaying
um a very topical Queens Gambit declined
A variation where the this early
exchange of Queens
but you get this double pawns on the F6
F7 for the two Bishops uh Theory
considers white to be slightly better
but
it it it's a slow play it is a slow play
and I have to say in the hands of the
right player it's actually very very
dangerous for black I have and uh I saw
Wesley beat uh one of these I can't
remember his name off the top of my head
but in the Champions chess tour I mean
it was very convincing performance by
whites right and so I would be very very
careful about essaying and opening like
this because you are in a groveling mood
I remember a game that Magnus won
against Vladimir kramnik also very very
very convincing we'll see uh what the
players have in store Wesley so you
mentioned Sam Shanklin and here we have
a rui Lopez again this time after Knight
F6 we have castles Bishop C5 immediately
and here we go with the move
c2c3 the difference here now is white
has not played the move D3 and after the
bishop either returns to B3 or even to
C2 we can see that white is ready to
play d2d4 in as we go one go instead of
the Stutter Step D3 D4 uh okay nice to
see a sharp there radical position on
the board C3 pardon me C3 B5 at the
moment as Wesley is considered Bishop B3
and or Bishop C2 and finally let's go to
that game of Ray Robson uh and fappy we
have uh Queen well at nimzo with the
Catalan catalan's getting very very
popular it is very popular and it's
actually very very popular on that
subject to actually intercept that check
with the bishop with the Knights I mean
this is a lot more sharper than normal
lines where you go Bishop D2 and the
bishop can Retreat itself to E7 or D6
and a game continues but you know whites
actually it's very trendy these days to
go Knight D2 and as far as I know it's
actually really good to take the pawn
not really good but you know it is the
kind of most principled way to handle
the position well well Ray believes you
yes he has in fact played the move uh D5
takes C4 is definitely the most testing
and once you touch that pawn once you
take it off the board you have to defend
it because after a castle if you give me
one more move and I have Knight takes C4
coming on the board that's going to
centralize my pieces that night probably
is going to land nicely in the center on
E5 this is going to be a dream position
for a wife also with this long diagonal
open for the bishop on G2 so you have to
do something and you have to defend that
pawn with the move B5 you have to
continue with that move and after that
as you were mentioning uh Jovi the
position goes completely bananas because
white is going to go A4 you're going to
steal defend that pawn with the move C6
probably and after that I was looking
through the database I've seen fun
Fabiano's name with the white pieces in
fact he played the game against uh
Knight ditch in 2019 I would assume this
was probably some sort of a rapid
competition and after Castle B5 A4 C6
just to give you kind of a taste of what
this position could look like in the
future B3 C3 where is the night going
back to B1 Knight to B1 Queen to C2 try
to get the pawn on a C3 Corral that pawn
on C3 with the uh the queen coming to C2
or to D3 a wild position ensues
nevertheless it definitely feels like
Fabi is ready for a fight in this one
nice uh B5 C6 I love these very sharp
cattle land so we'll keep an eye on that
and let's just go over to the ladies
yeah I'm glad that you said that yes
because I did something with my computer
did I lost it and I cannot welcome to
see me my very first return day of
return
to mess up day one uh we have a rule
basically in all broadcast where it's
the first day we can make every mistake
we want and
that's it at least twice at least at
least twice to be sure it was a mistake
the first time right and let's jump into
the game between Irina and tatv these
are two real veteran players for Tata is
must be thinking my gosh why was I why
of all of the U.S Champions that America
has had I mean always Arena and it's
like Tata has been the bridesmaid so
often and they these two have clashed
but it's really Arena who's been having
the upper hand and there we see what I
mean with the upper hand 13 wins 13 wins
four losses four draws so this is a huge
exactly active if she wants to tie under
the tide then she has to score now and
yeah of course Arena playing with the
white pieces Arena kind of just plays in
a very natural way you know she she gets
her pieces developed and then she builds
up for a nice middle game attack she is
quite aggressive like that exactly we do
have a kind of a quiet I want to say
nimso India on the board the last move
Bishop D2 by Irina forcibly reminds me
of an amazing game it was a game a man
vs machine as Gary Kasparov took on deep
Jr in New York a long a long time ago
and I recall that it was something like
Bishop D6 castles and probably there was
one or two other moves let's just throw
in some other move here say C6 and let's
say A3 something like this and the
computer right out of the blue played
Bishop takes H2 and electrified the
audience and Gary it was just like rock
back because in those days the idea it
was when the computer gave you material
or gave up material your toast yeah like
oh my gosh and Gary played King takes H2
and it was a Donnie Brook as his King
had to
take a walk uh
exactly and it was really really a lot
of fun I don't think that's going to
happen uh in today's game but uh it I it
was really remarkable to watch it Bishop
D2 uh beg him
she led the U.S women's team she was the
first board
and she's playing today against Katja
and I'm so far english four nights I
suspect uh I'm expecting that Kate will
just simply defend her Pawn with the
move Knight C6 do you have much
experience in these four Knights English
positions no you see my big thing when
playing with the black side yes is I
like light Square strategy so I'm going
to be putting my pawns on E6 D5 maybe
even C6 you know my Bishops yeah exactly
okay so I don't have that much
familiarity with this type of position
but I mean I've always Associated this
like a reverse resilient exactly and
indeed you it is and I have played tons
of games with G3 as well as E3 and I've
even been noting that some players in
this particular position like to say the
move A2 A3 so it's become
topical again what was once out of
fashion returns too fast and you know
what else is topical in this position
you were mentioning uh that you were
assuming maybe four nights are going to
land on the board in fact E4 is a very
popular yes it is really yes and after
Knight G5 C6 just giving up the pawn
like that you can take only four but
then I'm going to take I'm going to go
D5 and black is saying that I'm going to
gain so much speed on momentum with my
development and your pieces are not
going to be ideally placed that's going
to give me enough compensation now white
can respond with taking on e4 or this
very nice move Queen to A4 stopping for
the moment at least this one D5 and you
know what the move is uh in this
position the best probably the best move
for uh black I I was actually analyzing
this a couple of months ago B5
all I want to do as black in this
position is to get my pawns going down
the board you can take on C6 and if you
actually take on C6 after Queen C7 black
is better I'm going to regain my Pawn on
C6 D4 is uh going to come in the
position this is a bad news for white
quite a wild situation could ensue in
this position nevertheless she did not
play that she thought for a few minutes
maybe pondering his uh her options maybe
considering the move E4 but if you don't
know uh the theory in that position it's
not advisable to play the move E4 so she
did play the safe and sound option with
the move Knight to C6 and now we have E4
on the board this one is going to be a
strategical battle because after the
movie four we're going to see probably
D3 Bishop E3 Bishop E2 just a slow uh
game but take a look at this game
between Alice Lee and atusa and you are
mentioning Yasser a are calm name cell
well we don't have a common name so in
this one after the move Bishop to B4
Alice Lee chose the most aggressive
option option in this position and that
is the move F3 D5 A3 black has a couple
of options she can go Bishop to E7 and
after the move E4 take take and we've
seen this position in a lot of uh Elite
level games I remember that clash
between Fabiano caruana and Alex sayenko
from the candidates in 2020. that was a
big game that uh rejuvenated this
variation for black with Bishop E7
Bishop takes C3 was played take on C3
and now we have C5 C takes D5 another
ramification for blacks you can take
with the Knight on D5 or she can take
with the pawn but what I do see is that
she's spending a lot of time right now
atusa that is and Alice Lee she's on 1
hour and 33 minutes she definitely knows
what she's doing for that reason I'm a
little bit worried for atusa in this
early position yeah thank you for that
question thank you yeah I was curious
about this F3 line because I actually
seen it many times online by played by
the young Indian generation you know
pregnant uh good cash they all like to
play In This Very combative way
and I do get the impression also by the
clock time that atuse is kind of
freestyling it and she's reacting very
naturally you know challenging in the
center
um I think it is okay okay
yeah I thought the porn text was perhaps
a little bit more natural just because
if you're unfamiliar you might as well
put a pawn in the center and what I mean
what is White's plans though I mean just
to sit there well P3 probably I remember
that Knight takes D5 used to be
considered like the most rigorous uh
test if you will to White's uh position
because you want to take the pawn on
C3 and it's not that simple to defend it
for example if you play Bishop B2 while
you may not like the Knight coming to E3
if you play Bishop D2 this is something
that we should all be hardwired for that
we always have these checks that pick up
the pawn on D4 usually Queen D2 is
actually the main move and there's all
kinds of moves here including the move
F7 F5 and I remember the world
championship match in bond between
kramnik and
Vichy really investigated these lines
and I think even more recently just Dita
C5 would be the main line instead of
Queen to
d25 right and the end game after Knight
takes C3 Queen takes d8 is definitely
favorable for white I have the two
Bishops it's an open position Bishop to
B2 comes probably uh grabbing the pawn
on G7 as well this is not looking good
for black so black shies away from
capturing that pawn on C3 with a move
Queen to A5 we have this battle between
the two Bishops against a very bad
structure for uh white as well so this
is the battle in the position she chose
to shy away from that took on D5 with
the pawn and now we have a completely
different structure and we see the move
E3 Castle black is developing very
naturally in the position most likely
we're going to see uh Alice Lee follow
that up with the move Bishop to D3
follow that up with Knight to E2 just
simple natural development and Black's
plan in the position is to eliminate one
of the Bishops how do you do that well
you cannot eliminate the dark swear
Bishop that easily what you can do is
try to exchange the light Square Bishops
with the plan B6 followed by Bishop 2 A6
this is what I think we're going to see
in the position
and is it also possible just to kind of
say
how about your dark Square Bishop is bad
and I'll keep that locked in for the
rest of the time yes one of the most
amazing things about these positions
when you study for example the games of
Michael vardvinic as you think to
yourself
yeah that Bishop on C1 is probably a a
terrible piece and you're never going to
do anything with it and the crazy part
is it actually finds a very useful role
let me just throw some moves on the
board just so that you can get a an idea
of how Bob vinic used to play these
positions is he would bring his Rook
over and he'd wait for you to play
Knight A5 and then he'd hit you with
suddenly the move E4 and this bishop on
C1 Hood never bothered anybody
it suddenly it's like this monster
Dragon that's just a ready to go uh
Bishop to B5 so that Bishop to G5 so
it's something that you want to look out
for but I have to return to something
that a Christian
said for just a moment in the game
between bacon and
Katya because I want to remind everybody
this is a family
broadcast he was throwing pawns away
kids watched this show what the heck was
E4
did you get did you see that he just
blundered upon and he said it's a good
it's a good thing I could see your jaw
drop to the floor when He suggests that
move because you were like
yeah
Queen A4 and it was all sorts of
craziness that was going on boy we got
to be really really careful so we you
know be calm about throwing away those
pawns everybody C7 C6 that would have
been remarkable as it turned out what
actually happened to the game this move
E2 E4 has become a kind of a favorite of
Magnus Carlson of all people he likes
playing these lines with e4g through D3
G3 and it's like a reverse rosalimo he
gets yeah and somehow he does he
performs magic he does us because he can
simply continue prolong the game as long
as possible maintain the tension because
those positions are actually really hard
to play because all the minor pieces on
the board there's no clear apparent Pawn
break and both sides are just waiting
trying to expand with the pawns wherever
possible and you know for someone who
excels when they're applying pressure on
the opponent then Magnus is your guy it
surely is by the way there's one trap
here that's worth noting if Karcher
plays the move Bishop to C5 she walks
into a little bit of a shot Knight takes
E5 and the idea is you think to yourself
Bishop takes F2 King takes F2 Knight
takes E5 what's my problem it's material
equality
I've ruined my opponent's king
no no no castling the reality however is
after the move d4 blacks in in real
trouble of getting routed off the board
it's like really remarkable you suddenly
there's this big Center this wall of
Pawns white wants to play the move E4 E5
and she has the two Bishops so the move
Bishop C5 is actually considered a
blunder and you can't walk into this
move 95 and gotcha after some hesitation
play the move D7 D6
yeah Christian that strikes me as a
passive approach but okay it does in
general you have these moves these two
moves Bishop to C5 and Bishop to uh B4
she chose uh to play this move D6 which
allows white to just take full control
of the center with the move d4 right you
can see that on your board I'm ready
with a different game on this one but
yes after the move d4 it just seems that
white gains the center gains the space
advantage and is just enjoying a very
nice natural opening Advantage
absolutely but you have prepared
something on your board oh yeah complete
madness Okay going in this game between
Fabiano and Ray Robson and we were sort
of expecting this because both of these
players are just such theoretical
monsters they're very very good they
study and analyze eight hours a day
their openings they know it by heart and
this is exactly what we're seeing in
this particular matchup we saw the move
C6 and we are discussing previously
Bobby played the move B3 in that game
against Knight ditch C3 and Knight to B1
she he chose a completely different
approach with this move Knight to E1
which is indeed the main line in the
position there's a clear threat of
course I'm opening up the long diagonal
I'm threatening the move a takes B5 so
you have to defend the spawn on B5 can
you do that with A6 no because after I
take on B5 you cannot recapture with the
a pawn you're going to lose the Rook
because the a file opens up you cannot
recapture with the c Pawn either because
you're going to lose the so that's a bad
move he played the move Bishop to A6
this is the main line Knight to C2
Bishop to E7 take on B5 you're forced to
take back recapture with the bishop on
B5 Knight to B1 we see this dance of the
knights this Knight when D2 came back to
B1 this Knight G1 F3 E1 C2 and let's see
where that one lands Knight to C3 Knight
to D5 you have to defend against Knight
takes D5 everything makes perfect sense
and by the way Fabiano is blitzing out
his moves up to this point take on C3
Knight to B6 and this move
H4 which pretty much stopped Ray
Robinson in his tracks right now he is
spending a lot of time one hour and 18
minutes he blitzed all of his moves up
to this point unfortunately for him not
anymore because after this last move H4
which is the novelty in the position
according to my database well right now
he's in deep thought yeah
I mean this is always a good sign to get
your preparation in and uh great opening
to the tournament on day one and talking
about great openings we have to check
out some of the footage from the opening
ceremony that was held yesterday
[Music]
it's Halloween hosted
all the players very jovial mood they
[Laughter]
and all the players getting ready
listening to Chris bird these are the
letterman jackets that did the
commentators get a Letterman's jacket
unfortunately
request for us definitely by the way I
wanted to say that the guys picked up
their jackets faster than the girl I
mean the guy's jackets were gone they're
professionals so you can really see uh
The Marked difference uh please jump in
on this one for me Christian because I
can't believe it but the players have
reached the game between Arena and tatav
I I don't know if it's exactly uh the
same position I suspect it's not I think
A3 and B4 was tossed in but can totf
play the move Bishop takes H2 check
because that computer and she played
microwave six uh Bishop takes H2 was
supposedly not possible because my king
goes all the way to G3 so I don't go to
G1 obviously after Queen to H4 is very
difficult to defend against Checkmate we
know that Greek gift sacrifice you go
look to F1 I take on after I go back to
H4 and that's going to end up in a
Checkmate by you can go to G3 okay and
there's no follow-up we simply don't
have a lot of pieces what do you do you
give another check right for example
let's say queen to D6 right I can go
Knight to F4 and the best you can get
right now is to weaken your own King
with the move G5 or try to recapture uh
this uh last piece but unfortunately for
you check this move out boom Knight to
B5 I don't think this is the only move
in the position by the way I don't think
this is
wow it's a flashy one of course it's
going to give why the decisive Advantage
but the simple Rook H1 also works you're
going to take on F4 I'm going to take
back my king in fact it's very very safe
why is that because I have this bishop
on D3 so the Greek gift sacrifice
generally we see a Pawn on e4 stopping
the activity on this B1 H7 diagonal and
black usually can reinforce the threat
against the King on G3 with the move
Queen to G6 that's not possible in this
position Queen to G6 Bishop takes G6 the
game is over not only that but with this
diagonal open you have huge problems
with the pawn on H7 check this out
if you go F5 I'm thinking about this
potential idea F5 can I take on H7 wow
you take take on G4 and now I have the
other room coming to H1 with the
Checkmate and uh of course it's very
difficult to defend against that white
is winning in this position Rook takes
to H7 maybe it's a bit too much because
you do have G6 which wins for black but
forget about it it's just a beautiful
position I don't have to do all these
flashy things with roof X H7 I can just
play it slowly and my king on G3 in fact
is very very safe
yeah thank you I was gonna say it's very
rare that you see a king leading the
charge right in the middle game but
there you know it worked out very nicely
a good General always leads his army
into battle but wow Bishop takes H2 I
mean Knight A6 by the way that's a
pretty rare rare bird uh according to
our databases only one single game uh
has been played with the move Knight A6
uh to my eyes it is tempting for white
to capture this Knight and just say well
you've I've ruined your Pawn structure
for life I I'm still a bit worried about
this whole night G5 pardon me Bishop H2
Knight Knight G4 kind of complexes maybe
I take a timeout to play H3 after all
you know again my long-term uh strategy
is to work on this Pawn on C6 Knight A6
uh Christian rare
exciting is it is it a good move does a
computer approved
oh it's an okay move yes okay um so it
was actually seen in the game between
nepo and Dominguez so Knight A6 okay is
a rare move but um it has been seen at
the elite level Knight to G4 seems to be
the main line at least according to my
database but already at move 10. so this
is more or less a fresh uh position
Knight to G4 Knight to F4 if you do go
H3 probably I have some ideas some crazy
ideas with Knight H2 and then I'm going
to sacrifice on H3 or even go with the
move uh Knight to F3 take on F3 Queen to
G5 with the bishop here with the other
Bishop coming to H3 is going to be very
difficult to defend against the upcoming
checkmates if you go to F1 that's the
Checkmate in one move Bishop takes H3 if
you go to H1 then I can continue I'm
going to threaten Queen to G2 that's a
Checkmate and you have very few ways to
defend against that Knight to F4 I'm
going to meet that with Bishop takes F4
it looks very very good for black
knightway 6 is the move and I'm assuming
this Knight is not going to be for to
attack the bishop on D3 but rather
redirecting itself to E6 Knight to C7
followed by Knight to E6 and we know
that that Knight on E6 General is quite
well placed another Square potential
Square for the Knight would actually be
on D6 so let's say this bishop goes to
f8 Knight C7 98 Knight to D6 and take
full control of the square on e4 and on
C4 this is going to be a very
interesting strategical battle but white
does have Irina that is does have a big
option right now maybe why not take on
A6 right I understand I'm giving the
light Square Bishop I don't want to do
that but in return I'm getting a
beautiful attacking potential against
both the pawn on A6 and the pawn on C6
very very uh bad tremendous difference
between the structure that white has in
the position and blacks damaged
structure so this is going to be quite
an intriguing trade-off if she decides
to go for Bishop takes A6 white is to
move Irina is thinking this one is going
to be a fiery one I have to say yeah
thank you definitely agree with that one
actually I'm not sure I would actually
have the courage to take that night
because it's it's so risky and
especially when you kind of compare it
to other openings right but uh
definitely exciting for a big board in
the women's section exactly and and by
the way as we start our first day of
broadcast we want to encourage you to
join our show and they can join our show
very easily they can you can always ask
us a question you can send us comments
and just join in the fun generally and
you can do this by tweeting us using the
hashtag the American Cup and we will
feature them on the show where possible
exactly and we have kavitsky and Talia I
believe are Manning our social media
yeah getting ready for your Tweet so
join the show and we're very pleased to
say we have a guest joining us Jovi I
know and I feel like this guest needs a
drum roll because I mean it's super
special because coming up check it out
Gary Kasparov will be joining the show I
think he's going to be 60 years young
this year yeah yeah it's coming up I
believe April 13th April 13th yeah well
Gary we'll look forward to uh his
joining the show most definitely
absolutely get your questions ready for
Gary yeah exactly this now is your
chance to ask one of the world's
greatest legends have you met him no no
no it's impossible I mean I've seen him
in the distance as everyone has but I've
never actually like physically spoken to
him so it was like look at those things
you know I kind of grew up with Bobby
Fischer as like the so if you met Bobby
Fisher what question would you ask him I
always ask myself that kind of thing so
if you met Gary kasporov what's what's
the question you might
for Gary ah
I don't know if I think I would be
quivering I think I would be like um
yeah of course would probably go very
high pitched
I'm not sure and I would probably ask
the most ridiculous question ever better
bad I love it love it by the way just uh
checking out the game of um
Focaccia and bacon she did go for that
whole D4 and there is the move D5 now
because the Knight is pinned you might
say well let's just jump in and take
advantage of that pin with the move uh
Knight to D4 and this too
reasonable uh responses I want to ask
you Jovi if you had White's position in
this moment which one of the two
responses Bishop E2 or Bishop E3 which
you choose my vibe was Bishop E3 me too
I didn't really care so much about them
no no it's more about peace activity and
I kind of thinking that take with the
pawn
you've got all of these lovely breaks as
white and you're not feeling that the
double pawns are weak but they could be
used as a battering ram actually yep I'm
very much someone who really enjoys
pushing pawns so you're giving me my
dream position and Bishop E.T you
rejected because it was it's not bad
it's not bad but maybe you just felt
opportunity there was a better
opportunity yeah I mean one thing that
would make me very hesitant about
playing Bishop um British B2 is
primarily because I love my Bishops and
I would be afraid of Moves Like Knight
takes bishop and then you know I think
one thing I really fear in this type of
structure is what happens if black just
kind of
fianchetto's the bishop or maybe doesn't
even need to do that get the bishop to
E7 G7 doesn't matter castles the Knight
will step back and then boom
and I'm panicking already because I
don't have any control of the light
squares okay uh with the with the how do
you say a sturdy sander the pawns on c45
uh the light squared Bishop isn't like
it's the greatest Bishop you've ever had
here you might be thinking well it's not
so easy for for black to get in that
move F5 you might just end up 3 and G4
interesting we'll keep an eye on this as
we're going to turn it over to Christian
and what what about this position caught
you right Christian well it didn't
necessarily uh catch my eye but she is
my student begging so I did see this
position this morning uh we did look at
this we assumed that maybe she might try
this move D6 we didn't pay a lot of
attention to how the game could follow
up so after D5 Knight D4 in fact I told
her to play Bishop E2 so we'll see if
she is going to follow my advice or
she's going to do something else I see
she's smirking probably remembering our
conversations because she was a little
bit worried about the position I told
her don't worry about it you have the
center you can go C5 Bishop to E3
followed by C5 later on you're going to
be the first one that's going to deliver
the resounding attack because you know
white is going to try to push her pawns
on the queen side black as you guys were
mentioning in the style of the Kings
Indian is going to try to push her pawns
on the king side but Bishop to E2 is
also the engines top move inviting well
you kind of have to take on E2 or on F3
you have to do something about the
Knight on a D4 now that there's no more
pimp on the H5 D1 diagonal so we're
going to see how this one develops
nevertheless I feel white has achieved
her goal out of the opening and that is
to have a slight advantage
wow uh first of all uh Salud uh you you
had the opening preparation on your ward
I mean it's so hard to do that I need to
properly guess what your opponent's
gonna play we didn't spend too much time
on this one that's why I'm a little bit
concerned just because we didn't spend
too much time on this one
we understood that D6 is a possibility
but we also understood that it's very
very passive so we didn't expect
Katarina to actually play the move D6
but to follow it up with Bishop C5 or
Bishop to B4 the typical uh replies in
that position nevertheless it's going to
be a fight guys exactly uh quickly
before we go to over to the open section
I wanted to say that Alice Lee versus
satucha tusha did go for that line that
was prescribed by Christian which was
simply to trade off the two Bishops the
light Square Bishops came off after
Bishop takes A6 and pretty much coming
to this if you will bought vinnick
position because Michael badvinic really
showed that white
can
in a very slow but uh very concrete way
play for the move E3 E4 and if you look
at it from a development perspective as
well as a space perspective it's like
white has the free your game
so it's going to be very intriguing to
follow that matchup
and in case you've just joined us well
that's an upside down
let's take a look at the pairings yeah
for our Champions bracket
and and this is
in case you've just joined us here
here kids everyone's thoughts in this
bracket and here we are in the women's
section we see Arena Crush faced off
against old rival Tate Abraham and then
we have a tour
[Music]
it's making a return to chess and
finally we have 13 year old Alice Lee
against a Tusa very nice and again these
are match-ups so they're not tournament
round Robins they these are matches so
the winner of the match stays in the
champion it's a bracket the loser of the
match drops down into the elimination
bracket you get two lives essentially in
the tournament yeah you get a second
chance and you get relegated so to speak
to the elimination bracket not loses
bracket as other leaders losers no it's
not loserville here and instead the
players then speed up they start playing
at a rapid time control of 25 minutes
plus 10 seconds and then you just
survive you've got to win and just
turning our attention to the open
section I want to say that after
h2h4 in the game between Fabi versus Ray
Robson this move H4 you think well Ray
would have stopped and like checked that
move out no things continue to Pace A7
A6 now for me
I don't know about yourself uh I saw h4s
having said a you want to say B which is
you want to push Harry the H Pawn all
the way to H6 where it would really be
you know awkward for the black king upon
on H6 so I thought H5 H6 was
and now we go we go F4 we go Knight E3
we do something but yes uh that's not
following Modern Day rules what I have
noticed that 2700s they love to do even
2800s it's over protect every single
possible piece so that's why we saw Ray
Ray's A6
protect the bishop right you know
everything everything is protected and
if you do you know push the pawn to H5
that's a pawn that maybe is not
protected only protected by the queen
it's nicely exactly sitting nicely in a
chain at the minute so leave it there
and piece play instead but what the heck
is Queen H I mean somebody edumacate me
here H4 so you prepares the move Queen
H5 Christian I mean I'll try I don't
guarantee the level of the education
that you're going to receive yeah sir
because I don't understand this position
Missouri University coach that's pretty
I have the engine in front of me and I
still don't understand exactly what is
happening and what the point of this
move H4 is and queen to H5 the only
thing that I can think about is okay you
play Queen H5 you want to follow that up
with E5 followed by Bishop to e for
force a reaction from your opponent
because you are going to threaten the
move well Checkmate so for example A5 E5
let's just make a few moves on the board
Knight to D7 and finally Bishop to E4
now you have a couple of ways F5 is one
of them now that you have the Knight on
D7 and after he takes F6 you can take
back with the Knight defending the pawn
on H7 but let's assume that this Knight
would not be on D7 let's say the Knight
lands on A4 or stays on B6 and you have
to defend with the move G6 now we
understand what the pawn is doing on H4
I'm just simply going to retreat my
queen queen to E2 follow it up with H5
open up the H file and that's going to
probably give white a tremendous attack
now what do we have on the board he
played this move Queen to E8 after uh
quite a few minutes of thought Queen 28
is pretty obvious what black is trying
to do in the position and that is to
potentially hinder uh this queen on H5
with the move either F5 or F6 this is
going to be an interesting uh juggle in
the position if you do go the move uh E5
then I can follow it up with F6 that's
going to give me a very crucial Tempo
against the queen on H5 this is most
likely a better position for a black it
doesn't seem like white has the
initiative that he envisioned when he
played this move H4 especially after the
movie 5 you also give me the crucial
Square D5 for the Knight so it's a very
interesting position and right now
finally we see Fabiano stop and think
Queen to E8 most likely was not in his
notes he does have the option of just
retreating with the move Queen to G4
that creates an opportunity if you do go
A5 or Knight Wave 4 and not worry about
the king side well Bishop to H6 is going
to come on the board so let's say A5
Bishop to H6 this is going to give white
a winning position pretty much you
cannot defend you have to give up the
exchange and that's going to allow me to
get decisive Advantage crucial position
I see this idea of E5 Bishop to E4 maybe
even some sort of crazy sacrifices after
Knight to E3 Knight to G4 and then
Bishop to H6 or Knight to H6 it's a wild
position we know that Fabi most likely
has had this in his preparation so maybe
he doesn't know the exact precise moves
but he knows the plans and this is what
I'm having my eyes on and I'm keeping my
eyes on in this particular matchup thank
you for that Christian another game
that's just kind of blowed up on us we
haven't paid too much attention to it
when we left it it was a game between
Hikaru and Sam shankland this was this
modest D2 D3 move and after D3 well in
turn the modest D7 D6 not the more
aggressive Bishop C5 and or B5 followed
by Bishop C5 just D7 D6 and you say okay
well I'll just transpose to a classical
uh Rue Lopez where you know you've
played D3 and you're not going to do
anything ah no says uh Hikaru the move
C2 C4 uh
it supports Knight to C3 to D5 once I
get my knight to D5 I might get a nibble
okay
the players followed all of the standard
book moves up to this point we can see
with this move Knight D7 that the pin is
a temporarily uh prevented and you want
to play in the move Knight D4 and take
advantage of the fact that the Knight on
C6 can move we're going to stop you from
doing that Bishop E3 and all the moves
kind of went very quickly up to this
movement the move Knight f
eight I personally I found that a little
bit peculiar I thought it was time to
Castle and play Knight to D4 and or
Knight to C5 but night
um f8 Knight E2 now I don't know where
we are in terms of theory at this point
but after this move D3 D4
uh the position is really
double-edged it's like oh oh uh what's
going on Jovi uh break it down for us
how do you see uh This Moment well you
know white really has accelerated the
play here I mean no doubt about it do
think that like had to do this type of
strategy just to kind of cement down on
on the D4 Square okay and uh Hikaru you
know he has to seize the opportunity
right now and he does it with the Mover
so the first moves that I would be
considering is always you know the
checks the captures the true and the
threats right and so I would be looking
at porn takes porn
um how does the situation change yes I
have to retention I'm still I got you in
the pin so I'm not losing right away
exactly so that doesn't appeal to me too
much
um I kind of partially inspired by
Christian
Christian inspired that's a dangerous
I'm also thinking about the possibility
of just going B5 B B5 okay okay I
haven't worked it out because you know
you did spring this position of course
and then the whole idea is that you know
you give up this guy you give up the B5
Pawn just to get control over yeah
probably we have to take the pawn you
spoil uh your your your castling but the
center I mean yeah exactly this is dark
Square strategy what if I take on D4 no
uh with the perhaps with the bishop with
the bishop I don't want to give you an
extra Tempe
instead never never mind never mind
never mind so I have some tactics at
least I think I do I will take with the
Knight first night I will invite you to
take back with the pawn okay that's a
10. now I'm going to go Bishop B3
Bishop boy three oh okay
okay I was too smart for mine
and after Bishop takes night away you
have Bishop F6
was gonna go for that one there's a poor
number
that's what usually
usually
uh at the same time you know I will take
that with the king king takes F2 even at
the end position you're going to go
Bishop to F6 and yeah how do we assess
it because I do have a very strong
passer on A6 I'm going to go Bishop to
C4 the king is still a little bit weak
at least in my estimation on f8 I can
still go Rook to F1 King to G1 things of
that nature and how did we assess this
position a double edged Edge yeah yeah I
I see this as a three result game I can
I I I like being upon a head is white
the pawn on A6 but also the King on F2
it feels compromised I don't know I mean
uh depends on D4 none of this will
happen because he did take on D4 but
that just tells me that he's accepting a
long-term Advantage for white at this
point after taking on D4 I take back
tonight but is it is it that absolutely
cut and dry for you uh
coming to safety and then you know for
the moment for the moment take that I
will take on C6 oh really yes now I just
go castle and now I'm just saying that I
have a slightly better position I have
more space in the center and I have a
better structure whoa is that enough
whoa whoa whoa whoa there was a guy his
name was Emmanuel Lasker and you're
talking about he played these positions
as black
um and he I mean even even at the cost
of a doubled two double pawns he
actually showed that black with Dynamic
play could right even get a better
position because black kind of holds the
key to opening up the B line so I'm
thinking you know the Rook will swing
over to B8 thus this is the right rook
and then once it gets defended B3 then
you kind of can push open the position
with A5 A4
going straight into that variation and
it's not so easy for y to get I mean
black has his brakes Rook b8504 black
also has F6 F5 brakes d65 it's not like
White's gonna get breaks it's going to
be piece played by white right you know
moves like Rook over Rook up like for
example let's just
yeah and I'm really reluctant to play B3
yeah if I play the move B3 I'm
absolutely inviting you know there's
below 8584 and what I'm going to do
instead is I'm just going to kind of if
you will careful careful yeah sir
because white also has a pawn break C C4
C5 so I don't want to be allowing that
one my friend okay okay
too would you like to start with C5 yeah
my vibe is close that that breakdown all
right so I'm seeing a weakness and I'm
seeing a king walk so I'm gonna go Rook
to C1 to C2 uh in case you double I'm
gonna bring the king to C1 but this is
something uh that's oh wow I mean we're
really going into the dusty part of the
library and the players are are rushing
towards his ending they are indeed and I
just checked it with the engine and it
does give white tremendous advantage of
rubbishop takes C6 take on C6 yep B
takes C6 but now the key point is not to
allow you to go Bishop to F6 how do I do
that well I have a couple of options uh
with which I can try to achieve those
goals one of them is in fact long Castle
wow we just talked about a king walk to
get the king over to C1 yeah
E5 and now the game is pretty much watch
over you can take only five but I go
Bishop to C5 I'm going to capture the
exchange and you do not have enough
compensation as black in the position so
Bishop F6
out of consideration can you go C5 no
because you're pinned on the D file so
you don't have a lot of good ways to get
out of uh this situation as black it
does seem like white is just much much
better but whoa whoa whoa whoa I mean
just you know Kings on opposite sides
exactly
isn't this like a double-edged position
you're just saying that it's just better
for white it's like just better
much better just much better much better
wow I wouldn't have guessed that I
really would not I would have thought
that okay I'm going to put my queen on
E6 and you know your king is a
little bit more vulnerable than the
black king but uh quantify that if you
would uh how much better like after a
long time
one Pawn Advantage
0.7 right now but let's see what uh the
engine says after a bishop to G5 so King
to B1 Queen to E7 very well played plus
1.1 1.2 and yeah going up and in this
position H4 Bishop to F6 and just play
this position it seems like Queen takes
F6 Queen takes F6 G takes F6 this is the
ending with the King on B1 and I think
this is the crucial uh part I go C5 yeah
ah and I'm blasting your fast through
your structure in the position if you
triple your pawns then off The Rook to
C1 root take C5 a lot of you're going to
lose a lot of Pawns on that file this
one is not looking good and it does feel
like white has a very pleasant advantage
in uh this situation we'll see if thank
you for this maybe Hikaru is going to be
thinking about do I want to put the King
on the queen side in such an open
position on that side particularly or do
I would just want to go route to D1 and
save that King for the king uh King side
with short Castle
big big moment right now and we're going
to see whether Hikaru is going to go
with this aggressive long Castle or wait
for a few more moves you know that is
such a risky decision to Castle on the
other side you know you're castling
where there's a rook potentially
arriving on an open line I'm not sure a
human is gonna touch that with a massage
ball you know I think the brick coming
to D1 I think that one feels a lot more
natural because I don't know even if the
computer says it's plus one and it's
amazing for whites this is double-edged
and dodgy you know I can just see a
situation where you sacrifice a pawn
just to activate the Bishops and it's
computer chess and computer chess is so
different to human chess because human
you know have emotions we play with
mistakes we're not perfect and we're
always thinking about the future and how
it could all go wrong fast well exactly
in this idea of castling long uh taking
your king vulnerable Kings on opposite
flanks very very double-edged as we get
prepared for our first break we got to
talk about our friends at Q Boutique we
always have these specials and we invite
you our audience to enjoy the specials
that Q Boutique is offering what are
they offering today
entering the Saint Louis chess club logo
on the left and the 2022 American Cup
logo on the back this pullover features
a hood and can be folded and packed into
its own front zipper pocket perfect for
travel and it's available right now
online at Q Boutique stl.com
really perfect rain jacket if you will
and here it as they say I mean it really
does fold up very very slim are you
going to model it for us yes sir
probably not
but any in any case it's it's available
at Q Boutique so take advantage as we go
to our first commercial break
[Music]
thank you
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why just as
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
thank you
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
sound of personalized Health Care
like life and it's what you hear when
you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
we all know St Louis is a championship
Sports Town from the 11 time world
champion Cardinals to the Stanley Cup
champion Blues
but I bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world trust Hall
of Fame Westport social and Topgolf and
now even our own MLS team so whatever
Sports your team is into you can always
bring out your A-game in St Louis
oops sorry St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we are back with all the action on day
one of the American car and yasa good to
be back absolutely Joby uh we missed you
and it's nice to have you in studio
calling all the action when we left it
was we left the Hikaru uh Sam
um Savion game because it really had our
attention this uh this Rook endings and
the fact that we I so badly misassed
them the computers are giving Hikaru a
significant advantage and I was
questioning that and not doing very well
we did see the move Rook D1 and I think
here the controversy really gripped uh
the commentary yeah castles not a move
that comes easily uh Jovi no especially
not to a human I mean instead we saw
Hikaru do the same idea but in a safer
way and I think this is a very
understandable very human decision you
know get the same thing but with the
Rook on D1 and have the option of
running away with a game to safety you
know I like the running away
you know I'll move it to the right side
right move it to the right side okay
having said that let's suggest I do make
a move for example like rookie eight and
I'm assuming you want to put your king
into safety uh with the move castles and
this is where the controversy really
starts
um rearing its head is this idea that
Black's Pawn structure is quote ruined
two sets of double pawns and yet I've
studied the games of Emmanuel Lasker and
he showed on numerous occasions that the
double pawns have their Dynamics as well
I mean that you are you do have ideas of
F5 and D5 and sometimes when the pawn
gets to B3 you do have these ideas we
had been looking at such breaks as C4 C5
and concluded that white was for choice
but I was mystified as to why it was
such a high score that the computers
were giving your thoughts on that score
did you see it as white having this
significant advantage
to be honest do uh
I didn't I mean it wasn't until
Christian was like the guru you know and
came down and said no the computers are
saying this I mean I was in my cloud of
uh say ignorance let's say
and I just I just thought that black has
play you know because yes there are
double pawns but as you highlighted you
know you have the half open e-line to
start wielding some pressure and let's
not forget the root coming to the B8
square and then just just piling a lot
of trouble on the B2 pawn and you
highlighted some horizontal Rovers
absolutely jump in on this Christian
there's the computer still of the
opinion that wait is significantly for
choices well I do have to say please
that your guys's Instinct was spot on
because this is the fight in the
position are you going to be able to
play Bishop F6 and go into the end game
that you guys have been analyzing and
touted as good for black or not right
with the long Castle we understood that
Bishop F6 was simply just not possible
because of the move E5 with the King
only one E5 is not easily played right
so this is the big difference between
long castle and Rook to D1 Rook to D1
Bishop to F6 seems to be the best move
and my guess is that Hikaru looked at
this end game saw this bishop takes F6
Queen F6 Queen takes F6 and at this
position and assessed it as much better
for white nevertheless the more we look
at it we understand it's not that easy
right black just has this B file the E
file potentially to swing The Rook
rookie 8 Rook E5 and swing it either on
the king side or on the queen side
create some unpleasantries against the
pawn structure he can do that so it
doesn't seem like Bishop takes F6 after
Bishop to F6 gives white a huge
advantage and by the way he did not
follow it up Sam Savion we just saw a
move right now Rook 28 not Bishop to F6
so he's taking a completely different
approach it does seem like after this
move Rook to E8 we're not going to see
the move Bishop to F6 rather we're going
to see a a more passive approach Bishop
to f8 most likely defending that tender
Square on a G7 and maybe trying to
exchange the Bishops after the move G6
and then Bishop two a G7 nevertheless
once again the pendulum is swinging in
hikaru's favor of the Rook 38 castle and
we're back at plus one in this position
so it does seem like white is building
up his Advantage uh just to clarify uh
Christian I do like the move Rook E8 I
you did okay I did it very much and the
reason I like the move Rook E8 is
because in my view the immediate Bishop
F6 would have gotten this in this ending
where white has actually got this
Pleasant move King D2 where the king
could defend the pawn on B2 I actually
wanted to see White Castle which the
move rookie 8 provides so that after
Bishop F6 we do get into this ending and
but we don't
well we don't I'm not going to take on
uh F6 without you're not you're gonna
play E5 C5 C5 C5
I have more time right now with the King
sounds like a culture
okay okay I do I do admire the move I
mean you you you could create a
potential weakness on the D6 Square so
C5 rookie six you're going to go rookie
six okay so if I take on F6 are you
going to invite the queen trade
um yeah I'm thinking about it I need I
need I need some support let's do it
okay we're gonna trade Queens
we're gonna do it after a brief
hesitation what if I trade Queens with
Queen takes F6 okay probably okay now
you take with the Rook okay I mean
double pawns double pawns okay you that
there is a single weakness but if I'm
quick enough to defend it
well and that's the key in the position
I have to be fast as white if not I lose
my advantage right
um
to D3 Rook David three yes I'm starting
to look at maybe swinging first of all
we we we don't want you swinging
anywhere okay okay
Rook A3 I want to provoke B3 is what I'm
trying to do with this movie with B8
yeah yeah I really don't like this move
B3 but I probably have to play it so
perhaps maybe I should have started with
Rook to D2 can we go one move back
there's no there's no back crank tricks
yeah but okay I anytime I get a four
versus three I'm gonna claim that I'm
that's um you know how to make a draw
yeah I know how to make a draw
um Rook D2 okay
um is this like the end of the world or
something no absolutely okay
so Rook to C1 Rook to C1 okay that was a
little bit of a surprise you can still
come in with you where you can see the
ring with the D1 as my main rule I
thought your move was Rook to D1 but
Rook the C1 okay you can still go King
A7
yeah because your whole idea is after
porn takes you actually take with them
right yeah defending but I'm thinking
that
why do I need to defend anything let's
just yes sir I I really let's just go
okay now I take on D6 take aunties how
easy is this 26.
so what if I take on CC yes take on C6
take on A6 and there's two parts two
connected passers you know it was really
so shocking The Rook on D2 is stopping
my intended Brook check and uh Rook
takes F2 uh just defends yes you're
right uh apologies uh
[Laughter]
well at least in this particular case I
mean it may not be much but at least you
can make a claim yeah yeah
I think you have enough the the material
is so limited in the position true true
um and also back here when you did trade
on F6 there was a question like I mean I
do keep my Dynamic uh potential uh with
the Rook for the moment it's a Tempo
let's say
wow okay we're we're gonna leave uh
these two because so many exciting games
are going on let's quickly check in on
Lavone and linear
yeah and before we do that let's go
check out the Champions bracket remember
these everyone's matches these are our
matches and everyone is playing in the
classical format so that is the time
control of 90 minutes plus 30 seconds
one game today one game tomorrow and if
the head-to-head matches are tied
tomorrow we are going to start seeing
some tie breaks I see and some shorter
tie breaks and maybe even some
Armageddon and again it's a double
elimination Double match elimination so
anybody who loses the matches of today
they go into the elimination bracket and
uh well uh jumping into the game this is
the linear Dominguez levonne aronian
very very standard I want to say middle
game has come out of this opening we see
the the
um I want to say the characteristic of
this particular defense by black I think
you described it pretty well ugly chess
you've got these double F pawns the
pawns on F7 F5 they do control good
squares the bishop looks really kind of
forlorn
like one big Pawn but unless you do
something the bishop will actually one
day just play
around the board okay so uh not much to
say about the position although I do
like white uh the game between Wesley so
and Sam Shanklin now this is actually a
huge matchup both these players coming
from Berlin yeah where the west side was
first Sam was second Sam took care of
the streamers as he said but Wesley took
care of him which is why Sam was second
and Wesley was first
that was how Sam described it at dinner
to me last night
[Laughter]
yeah definitely and we're here I mean it
just seems like I personally really like
Wesley's position really and break that
down first why is that well
it's Carlson and vision and and I
remember Vichy had these double Pawns in
the middle and it looked like nothing
was going to be happening but Magnus
worked his magic and absolutely tortured
uh Vichy Anna because of these pawns
because you know they're not very
flexible they can't prove so easily and
any kind of capture towards the Santa is
either I mean here it favors white so I
I don't know I don't like these things
very much but on the flip side let's not
generalize it too much I mean black does
have a lot of piece Play Active lines
still
double your pawns don't like them yeah
I'll just jump in uh for a moment and
I'll uh somehow as you were talking
forcibly reminded me of a passage from a
book written by Grandmaster love Albert
now Lev Albert was one of those players
as black he told you if you let me play
the benko Gambit I'm playing the Banco
Gambit
and if you let me I'll play the
alachines defense and like he's just
warning everybody those are my two
defensive weapons
so he had a student and he was teaching
the student how to play the Benco Gambit
and the student shied away and said no
love I I don't like it because
Grandmaster Anatoly karpov the world
champion just beat somebody like it was
nothing in the uh Benco Gambit and love
said dude that was the world champion
like you got to play what is is close to
your heart you know you just okay Magnus
can beat anybody it wasn't necessarily
the double pawns that beat vishy maybe
it was you know so I'm not sure that the
position is one of those that you know
you should just be discouraged because
you know Magnus won a game uh in this
particular situation the move D6 D5 by
the way comes with uh I don't know if a
threat is the right uh way of putting it
but if if black was of that mindset that
the pawns shouldn't be moved he could he
could have started with Rook B8 or Rook
b85 I apologize or queen D7 but the move
d65 is Sam's way of saying hey look I'm
not going to just sit still and wait for
you to build up and you know create I'm
going to do something I I I agree with
you there and there is a concrete threat
in the position I mean black is actually
threatening probably to go d5d4 right
and attack the rook and the pawn right
if you you know that is one threat and
if you take some measures against it I'm
primarily thinking get that rug out of
Dodge oh just drop it just drop back
okay or even Queen City I quite like
your Quincy twos about it that's all
right but and then with the same idea
that once D4 comes Rick we'll drop back
to E1 right and you're just going again
you know those double Pawns in the
center
I understand but you're getting a little
fixated okay the pawn on E5 E6 you know
long term I I definitely got to do
something short term you know the move
Queen D6 connects the Rooks
um I think it was uh Michael Marin it's
at you know like uh bad pawns control
squares like even though the pawns on E5
and E6 are potentially weak they do
control squares the pawn on A5 stands
out a little bit maybe Queen C5 uh in
other words I for for me the jury's out
how about you Christian uh you you break
the tie no break the same for me it's
one of those positions that I'm looking
at the engine eval and I understand that
I don't know what I'm talking about
[Laughter]
I see 85 I see that I have more space in
the center as black I see the weakness
that you were mentioning the pawn on A5
that The Rook is tied to and I feel like
black is just having the better place
pieces in the position which should
potentially give him the advantage I
look at the engine eval and the engine
eval is telling me that white is
actually better in the position now I
also look at the time
check this out Wesley so we know he's
generally a very quite a fast player he
almost never goes into time travel he's
on 40 minutes right now while Sam is on
a comfortable one hour and 15 minutes
and this shows me that Wesley probably
doesn't like his position as much he
doesn't see uh there's no Clarity for
him in the position he doesn't know
where to put the piece is what's the
plan right now he took on D5 by the way
which is a very committal decision and
after taking on D5 it doesn't seem like
this is recommended by the engine either
but the Knight takes D5 why not right
yeah well that was the thing I mean
jovia is going to say that you can't
take on D5 because if Knight takes D5 is
a Tempo you got to go sorry you have to
go all the way you've got to go all the
way back if you go to E4 or E2 I take on
C3 and that's going to capture uh The
Exchange as well so you only have one
option you have to go Rook to E1 and in
fact I'm not going to take on C3 because
after Queen to C2 both Knights on the C5
you're going to lose one of them right
that's why you want to have the Rook on
E1 so this Knight on C3 doesn't attack
The Rook the problem is I also have this
idea of going Knight to F4 going for the
D3 Pawn a very soft and tender uh set up
for a white also potentially after
Knight to G5 do I have ideas of Queen to
G5
it does seem like white has the Saving
Grace Queen to G4 and now we go into
this end game which seems to be uh just
simply equal nevertheless it does feel
like white is on the defensive in the
position I like what Sam is doing in uh
this one but guys yes let's take it to
this game for just a second the game
between Fabiano and Ray Robson because
whenever I look and I try to assess the
players I'm looking at Trends well let's
take a look at Ray's Trend right now he
just passed 2700 for the first time in
his career with an incredible
performance during the U.S Chess
Championship in October last year
Fabiano on the other hand well he's been
for a very long time over 2 800 in the
last couple of years not so uh hot
unfortunately for him it doesn't seem
like this position is good either and
race finding all the best moves in the
position check this move this last move
that he just played Rook to d8 I really
like it Fabiano responded with the move
Knight to A3 now we look at the move
Rook to d8 what is that Brook doing on
d8 can you guys guess It prepares the
move C5 It prepares the move E5 exactly
exactly and what do you couple that with
what what an attack on the pawn on PC
sorry oh yes Knight A4 so we started
with the move Knight to A4 right if you
defend with the move Queen to F3 which
feels more or less natural
then I can go with this idea of E5 and
after that as you were mentioning and as
you were spotting it so clearly Yasser
black is going to have a nice
infiltrating move Rook to D3 so Knight
to A4 Queen to F3 E5 you take I go Rook
to D3 and your position actually
crumbles yes
right now The Rook on D3 is a powerful
piece so how do you defend this Pawn on
C3 after Knight to A4 well you also have
the option of going Bishop to D2 and now
we see once again why the Rook on d8 is
so well placed I have a lot of options
one of them is even this move Knight to
C5 try to get the Knight to B3 or to D3
if you do take on uh C5 I take on D2 and
you have a losing position so after
night wave or if he finds this move it
just feels like black has the better
play in the position and once again
we've been wondering this since the move
H4 what is White's hand on the king side
I understand you're pushing the pawn you
get the queen to H5 but how do you
continue the attack and if you don't
have a clear way to do that maybe you
just lost a few crucial tempies and
right now you're in a worse position as
white wow
um yeah that I'm still I have to be
honest I am mystified by H4 Queen H5
yeah it's gonna be a long long session
for you to explain that one uh to me
Jovi that that was that's strange I want
to remind everybody we have a special
guest yeah we absolutely do I mean check
this out at 4 P.M that says
[Laughter]
there was former world champion Gary
Kasparov will be joining the show yes
and you can remember to tweet any
potential questions you might have for
the former world champion using the
hashtag the American
exactly turning our attention to uh the
game between uh Alice Lee and uh atusa
it followed exactly the prescription I
had been mentioning I believe
um yes let me just make sure I have the
correct position oops no here it is
no it didn't go it did I think it did it
didn't it takes takes rookie ah she
played C4 I apologize so it was like
Knight G3 Rook A2 Rook E2 C4 by Alice
um
that feels like it it lets black a
little bit off the hook doesn't it takes
takes 97 takes Knight is wow the night
is great on C5 uh just kind of it's a
stable Outpost uh White's Bishop is
nice but no I'm I'm feeling like this is
closer to a balanced position than it is
Advantage either player uh the move
Bishop G5 you you're setting up for a
capture and one of the questions you
might ask is how great is it like okay
if you were if I forced you to uh trade
off thinking the same thing yeah in fact
I was thinking there's a very strange
pattern happening yeah
it's very rare to get doubled airports
but we've got it now like in three games
we're doing our best you know so okay we
feel this is a little bit balanced let's
go to our veterans matchup between Arena
Tata this is the one where I've been
trying to sacrifice a bishop on H2
almost from the get-go for Tata didn't
happen uh A3 F3 C5 takes Bishop takes
I'll ask uh Gary about the his game with
deep Jr what he felt when Bishop takes
H2 was played against him and we have
this position on the board isolated
Queen Pawn but
how do you feel about these apples King
H1 was the last move by Arena I find
that this positions in general were very
difficult to assess I mean primarily
because all the minor pieces are still
on the board right and that means
there's so many possibilities like for
instance the white dark Square Bishop
could go to C3 could even go to E1 and
go out to H4 and you know there's a lot
of pressure white pieces are very very
active this light Square Bishop on D3 I
mean it's pointing it's shooting arrows
towards the H7 Square so and of course
take a look at Black's counterparts
sitting there at home and not easy to
get out but of course everything is
offset as you pointed out by that long
term pressure you know that there's
pressure on E3 right
um I'm hearing double-edged three result
game uh I feel the same way completely
let's jump to begum versus Katja when we
left it we were around these parts
Bishop E2 a move prescribed by chess
coach and Legend Christian
Bishop E2
did your pupil uh do do well I'm hoping
I will get a thank you coach
I hope it ends up well for well I look
I'm impartial of course I'm coming to
your army partial in this one but she
did get everything you could ever dream
of in this position with the white
pieces because let's take it back a few
moves after Bishop to uh E2 she decided
to take with the bishop on F3 we were
discussing these ideas of uh going with
Knight takes C2 Queen takes C2 Bishop to
E7 you do attack the bishop I'm going to
retreat back and then the typical King's
Indian uh conversions I'm going to try
to go Bishop to E3 followed by C5 open
up the position as white on the queen
side that's where I have space Advantage
black on the other hand is going to take
advantage of the fact that she has the
two Bishops and try to open up the
position on the king side towards my
king so you can Castle I go Castle I get
this uh Knight out of the way and then I
follow that up with the move F5 and
that's going to be a very complex battle
ensuing
if you do what she did in the game with
Bishop takes F3 Bishop takes F3 the
problem is after take take take on F uh
three you have to take on F3 so that the
Knight survives on D4 and you don't lose
a pawn take on C6 and we get this
position which just screams and tells me
that I mean white is so much better
because I have what to play for you
don't now what do I mean by that Rook a
B8 B3 very natural moves so far my plan
my next move in fact is going to be C5
how do you stop me from The Well of
course I can also take the pawn on A7 if
you allow me to do that so you do have
to defend against Bishop takes A7 maybe
Rook to B7 or the move A5 but I'm going
to follow that up with the move C5
that's going to damage your Pawn
structure you cannot play you're not
ready to play D5 you don't have a rook
on d8 so if you take on C5 I'm going to
follow that up with Knight to A4 I'm a
pawn down for the moment but I'm going
to recover with Bishop takes 5 and
Knight takes C5 at the end of this whole
situation I'm going to have such a
better structure as white I'm going to
have a potential Target on C6 a
potential Target on A5
and it doesn't feel like black has any
uh counter chances for that what do you
guys see in the solution I love playing
against the split pawns and I love this
uh move C5 in particular
I'm not sure I like hachi's Rook
a a to B8 move if I if I can be a little
critical uh right here at this moment uh
when I played the move Rook B8
yeah I'm essentially saying you know I'm
going to lose a Tempo against the bishop
takes A7 and I really see myself in a
situation where I want to meet the move
C5 with D5 so For Better or For Worse uh
I'm thinking I should have played the
move Rook B8 and if you play B3 well
then I can consider what else to do
should I play uh A5 or what have you the
problem that I'm having is exactly in
the in the game position yeah this is a
natural move
but boy I just don't have a good follow
I don't have a good reaction to this
move I can play Rook d8 but then it's
all about these things two guys are just
Strays you know they're loners right
right and it and it's much easier for
begum you may just get the coach of the
day award stay tuned that's that's all I
could ever ask for exactly it's a
remarkable but before we get too far
into Davis one's broadcast it's it's
that time that we dream we have to make
our predictions
and as you're the guest of honor uh we
we put you in the hunt today yeah thank
you for that let's start with uh the
ladies okay the open section yes look at
your choices all mouth-watering eight
great okay players I am gonna go for the
legend himself the one and only Hikaru
Nakamura I think he's just got the
nerves for it he's got the technique
[Music]
courageous historians will call you
courageous
not bad and in the ladies and in the
ladies
um okay this one again is tough and I
have a lot of face
Anna Arena crash but she's going to be
run a close second by Ali Alice League
who I think is such a tremendous Talent
yeah so you're convincing yourself not
to take one of the two top seeds that's
that's Brave you want me to no no no no
no no no no no I want you to choose your
winners I I think again I would go for
arena but I I do realize that you know
I'm not being very out there with my
choices as well number one seed and the
number one seed I I feel you I feel the
pressure the pain it's tough I'm gonna
go with Arena even though I do imagine a
a clash between number one and number
two in the finals but I like Arena and I
like Wesley so why am I choosing Wesley
so I saw him in Dusseldorf he was very
very calm he did lose one game but he
was very impressive in his performance
in Berlin was a wake-up call for
everybody he played tremendously yes so
I'm I'm gonna go with Wesley and Irina
as my choices and
how about you Christian that's so brave
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they ended up in fourth place which was
quite good uh given that they were ninth
seed if it's not mistaken and she had a
great performance in that one and she's
been training well and I know that uh
for a fact so I do believe that she has
a good chance nevertheless this one is
going to be super disputed Alice Lee
also in great shape coming into this
event so uh definitely a contender but
I'm going to go with beg him in this one
and in the open section
Hikaru is out I cannot pick him I I
don't want to side with Jovi I don't
want to side with you look you're a
podcaster get out of here
if you I mean if you didn't go with
begum and if you didn't go with Bobby
you you you're off the Christmas A-list
no Thanksgiving dinner there's no
Christmas
going into this one but I am going to
pick Fabian okay and we have erosion
virusian is going to pick Lavon yeah
yeah yeah you like and Alice Lee yeah
okay I like his choices too I do like
his choice I mean that the problem with
choosing any of these amazing players is
the Fantastic right I mean we just saw
the one around in here he won the WR
Masters as you say Wesley who was so
impressive in the Armageddon chess yeah
and also he's just impressive full stop
right and of course Fabian Carolina is
just and by the way as far as fashion
statement go if this isn't a batik shirt
from Indonesia it feels like to me I
actually have a couple of those but they
look so much better on him than they do
so I don't wear them out of fear of
comparison yeah well he's not a favorite
stylish stylish uh I think he regularly
wins like the best dressed Award right
he stands out he definitely stands out
and uh Christian coming to you what game
has caught your eye well I was looking
at this game uh that you guys were
looking at as well the one between Alice
Lee and percussion and it did feel
indeed that C4 was not the right
direction for Alice and that showed me
that she's not really familiar with
these structures because in this
position instead of C4 you have a lot of
other options but generally what you
want to play is play the move E4 get
ready to play that move E4 how do you do
that well one of the most
straightforward ways is to just simply
support if or with the move Knight to G3
and after that E4 Knight to C6 is a
potential move to try to stop the movie
for because after that you don't have
enough Defenders on the pawn D4 and
generally a lot of the games in the
position uh continue with the move
Bishop to B2 Bishop to B2 it looks ugly
you're facing your own pawns with this
bishop on B2 it looks like a Pawn on B2
but after I play the move E4 E5 if you
do take on e4 and open up the center
this Pawn B2 is going to become a
force to be reckoned with in the
position so definitely an intriguing
situation she did think for a long time
and she played the move C4 which does
allow black to simplify the position and
to be honest probably to equalize but
after the move Bishop to G5 she should
have stayed active in the position with
the move Rook to D6 instead of that you
play the move Knight to D7 you don't
like it that opens the opportunity of
just simply jumping with a knight to D4
starting to look at that square C6
starting to look at potentially
weakening your Pawn structure on the
queen side these are two pawns that I'm
focusing on the pawn on A7 and the pawn
on B6 if you try to go Knight to E5 well
Knight to F5 is an option Knight to B5
as well is an option if you go A6 I go
Knight to C3 back or Knight to C7 and
you're going to lose uh that pawn on A6
so it does feel like despite the fact
that she did not find the right approach
Alice Lee is still in control of this
game if she finds this move Knight to D4
and she is our youngest competitor by
far and I was saying at the top of the
show that she's been leading the Saint
Louis Arch Bishops into battle and she
has indeed in their last match up she
actually beat a 2700 plus player she
beat Daniel Bogdan Dak from Romania with
the black pieces so she's definitely in
tremendous shape she has the confidence
going into this event she knows that she
already reached the final well how can I
top that win the event win the title and
there's definitely you can feel that
confidence coming from her right
I just helped me out here we just saw a
graphic that said three times she has
won the World Championship world
champion three times for youth yes and
is that like under 10 under eight under
six what what is that no on the six I
mean you know yeah yeah this will be
under 12.
so maybe she's won that twice and and
all the way up to under 18. under 18 so
a sixth in the world is considered a
used as well okay under 20 is the junior
you know that because he won that
tournament uh but yes it's eight to
under 18.
wow okay so three times you know I mean
just stop I mean you're 13 year old
you're a veteran if you've won three
world championship titles get out of
here you're a veteran I wanted that once
and I was super happy yeah
I imagine you were this is going to lead
my life
she wanted three times already at 13. I
mean what a talent we have on our hands
amazing I wanted to turn your attention
especially uh for Christian because he
chose Bobby as the Open winner take a
look at what Ray Robson has done after
we saw the move Knight A3 Knight A4 gift
Meet The Pawn on C3 how are you going to
defend it it's rather awkward but here
came Queen F3 and what was that Rook on
d8 doing well
in chapter 20. yeah well this doesn't
take rocket science to see that if you
do take the pawn on E5 Rook D3 comes
with oomph I mean oh dear Pawn on C3
defend your choice uh Christian for a
moment well what is he supposed to do
when I did consider Fabia as my choice I
forgot how bad his house
and he's playing with the white so
that's it's called it's called Buyer's
Remorse by the way yes yes quite early
on after buying it
um yeah no after A5 it's looking
tremendous for a black nevertheless he
is thinking for quite a long oh he
didn't play E5 he hasn't played before
residual of our analysis I thought it
was on the board you know why because
both E5 and C5 are attractive feel very
natural indeed C5 you're also maybe
opening up the path for that Bishop to
get back into the game via C6 there's
options right in position and right now
Ray Robson is considering them C5 also a
move E5 also let's see what he comes up
with we still have a battle on our hands
don't forget about that after E5 I'm not
forced to take on E5 right after E5 I
can just simply go Knight to C2 and
defend the pawn on D4 like that
and my guess is this is what Fabiano is
hinting at with this last move knightway
3 and queen to F3 he's trying to get the
Knight to C2 and defend upon on D4 uh
like such still an intriguing position
the computer is uh assessing this as
quite much better for black nevertheless
I'm looking at it and from a human's
perspective is not that clear what do
you guys feel about it I feel the same
because I've been on the receiving end
of this type of position where you know
you put it up it looks like it's all
holding your opponent makes a few moves
and then you just make a blunder and
that's it
and I I don't think it's so easy for Ray
you know after all just take a look at
his pieces you know if you support your
stronghold on D4 yeah then The Rook on
f8 not great The Queen Is Not Great and
this bishop on B5 is still very much a
glorified Pawn so well my perspective is
I I I'm grooving with Rey completely
think that black is just overwhelming
take a look at the Knight on C2 so a
moment ago Christian was saying well
Fabi is thinking about bringing the
Knight to C2 well it was on C2 you
played the move Knight A3 and after
Knight A4 the queen has got to drop back
I love this move E5 and now if you want
to play Knight C2 it seems to me like
you've lost two Tempe to establish the
same position you had a moment ago I'm
not saying it was pretty
but I mean needs must right yeah right
you have to after E5 support the center
because I think porn takes porn is just
too easy for life can I win something
here I I'm I'm looking at a rook text D4
go for it right
here okay
can I go night takes yes uh sorry but
that's a rook on E1 yeah uh I'm sorry my
intention of course was to skewer your
Rook forgetting about the fact that the
Rook on E1 supports your E5 if your
queen had to move then can you start
with Bishop F6 first okay instead level
takes before let's let's have a look-see
uh Bishop E3 problems
fantasy five maybe you can still go E5
and what now is the question yeah
do you have no you don't have any fans
um
now I can just simply go Bishop B2 I
think Bishop boy two yeah wow if you
take on D4 you take one c three take on
f8 and then at the end of it I I
consider here and be a peace out yeah
right
wow okay uh so I can't immediate uh
immediately crash through I guess can
you go Bishop F6 yes yes perfect five my
time exactly Bishop F6 uh fits in and
now I played H4 guys oh no G5 I thought
you were gonna play Bishop A3 and I was
ready to sacrifice an exchange uh for uh
a huge Center maybe finally that on an
H4 doesn't it makes sense
um but still you can build right you
still you can go like take some time out
and go H6 but it feels like why first of
all White's not even completed a
development what is White's threat like
if White had the move like what would
you consider you can play Bishop E3 that
would hang the C Pawn you can't even
play Bishop to D2 because we've already
seen a knight
potentially jumping to the the square
it's not so is this completely
foul to play a move like H6 uh just
saying your turn like go ahead and make
a good move if you can
um I do like race position and he is
thinking about the move C5 as well okay
perspective and now maybe we're starting
to understand decipher what that Knight
on A3 is doing once you play the movie
five what if I take on C4
perhaps this is what fob is hinting at
okay this type of positions you take on
D4 I take on D4
rectangle you take and I go Knight D3
and I try to say that you do have an
extra Pawn but I have that Knight coming
to F5 maybe I have some mating
ideas
makes by the way this is the best
position I've seen for white in some
time I mean here I kind of feel like I
understand H4 is being useful uh Knight
F5 uh I I begin you'll be surprised
after Knight E3 the computer doesn't
like the position that much for white
Bishop to B4 being the main move but you
can think about this and calculate it
from afar and not be able to assess this
properly right you see the Knight on E3
the Knight landing on F5 you start
getting scared especially if you're in
uh raise shoes right now with all the
pieces coming towards your king so I can
understand why Rey is right now stopping
thinking and trying to assess his
options E5 is one of them but let's not
forget he has plenty more C5 another one
maybe even just slow play as Jovi was
saying H6 going to D7 something along
those lines but and if you're worried
about Nike takes porn could you just say
hey let's agree a draw by going Knight
B6 invite the repetition okay
something to think about uh
two things that really caught my
attention here when I saw the move
Bishop before you're gonna love this
people think you know like I'm a slow
positional player no I'm actually a
burning tactical demon after the move
Bishop B4 I I like that I like that
yesterday I I I I I think about
sacrificing a rook with Knight F5 and
Bishop H6 uh you're on the feeling the
spirit of Larry Christensen you must
have walked into the building you're on
to something also after which page six
Queen E4 you can probably resign but oh
no Queen E4 I have so much material that
I can give you a lot back gotcha you
take back on e4 I take back you the
bishop C3 defender on G7 and be okay
gotcha that's a nice one that's simple
but you don't have to do it Knight to
five was the right approach and after
Bishop takes C1 maybe I can just simply
take the Rook back on a D4 same idea
very complicated position it's easily
understandable why he got scared and he
shied away from it and that's why he
played C5 and by the way uh after Rey
went into a deep think and did play I
think it's a very human move by the way
uh the move C5 instantly yeah
D5 and you were mentioning that Ray
could have also retreated the Knight and
potentially offered offered a draw
yeah he didn't he went C5 and instantly
came D5 and those are very very big
differences between the E5 and the C5
how Christian did the computer light the
move C5 definitely E5 was the preferred
option after C5 D5 it does seem like
white is getting closer to establishing
the balance in the position the dynamic
balance in the position because it's not
an equal position it's not uh the
traditional equal position it's a very
dynamic position D5 Bishop to F6 is an
option you can start by taking but
naturally at least from a human's
perspective opening up the E file with
the Rook on E1 and the Queen on E8
doesn't feel like the right thing to do
so I'm expecting Bishop to F6 which did
indeed came on the board most likely
we're going to see a quick uh turn
around with this move uh
yes I would be looking at
looking at the pawn moves to e E5 yeah
but they have what if I take right yes
yes reversing the pin and The Rook uh
look it's an option yeah it's an option
white still has plenty of compensation
maybe now can go H5 but this block of
Pawns yeah once it starts rolling down
the board with the move d4 it's going to
become extremely aggressive and very
very quickly that's going to happen so
he takes D5 was the party pooper yeah
you need to be careful yeah nonetheless
I'm sure Fabiano right now is going to
stop and start thinking along those
lines with the move E5 and perhaps those
were uh race thoughts because he thought
for a very long time
for this decision to place the move C5
maybe these are the variations that he
was calculating in his mind
okay but after Bishop F6 there's some
very concrete lines that you you want to
look at and I think you have to start
with Bishop T2 and then you have to look
at the consequences thereafter right
Bishop to D2 okay now I'm thinking E4 E5
is an extremely serious threat like you
just you just don't want to see these
pawns landing on E5 and D6 actually I
think maybe your Bishop's even getting
trapped so E5 is a threat you have to
capture right
help me if I'm if I'm steering wrong
correct yeah take take and there's a
Tempo and then get out of there right
and now I've got this pass Pawn on D5
I'm beginning to feel like you know I'm
the one now
doing well uh I'm not exactly sure what
my follow-up actually is why it would be
like H5 right an interesting H5 is one
of them but what about G4
G along the same lines right yeah I had
thought about this but then you know my
calculation went as far as Bishop takes
born and well maybe let's not dwell on
the left side anymore okay but I mean
it's kind of like a little bit off-site
I don't know maybe it's usually starting
to become extremely concrete very uh you
have to go F6 right and that softens up
the light squares which page three and a
lot of very crazy calculations are
coming your way yeah it's it's the
position blowed up uh and I don't think
in Rey's favor I I really preferred that
E5 to the C5 and okay besides Bishop T2
I don't have a choice though uh maybe
the idea of E5 that we were discussing
right E5 allow you to take on D5 and
just play that position
say that I have some sort of confidence
like something like this right but these
three pawns just were just so
off-putting I didn't yeah they're
they're scary once you go D4 you know
probably is coming right uh but unless
you land a Haymaker on the king side E6
H5 and perhaps H5 first
so with the bishopone F6 without playing
the move pitch by 4 maybe H5 first now
my idea is that if you do play the move
H6 with the bishop on F6 I can take on
H6 no no as black yes yeah
so if we play H6 instead of D4 then
I can take on H6
but as you were mentioning D4 it just
looks so good right right right
um well now we see an advantage of this
move C5 you don't have the move Knight
takes C4 anymore because the queen also
defends the Knight on A4
so just In This Moment a moment ago with
the part when the pawn was on C6 Knight
takes C4 Bishop takes a bishop takes E4
would be meant by Rook takes A4 now
unfortunately we perform on C5 and not
on C6 The Rook is hanging to the queen
so it's a kind of a like a sneaky Motif
it's a sneaky little move to get in
there Bishop
um I'm assuming Bishop G5 is bad for the
reasons of Bishop C3 is that true
Christian that is true yes that is true
the bishop G5 is in fact very bad
because 63 and black is just doing
tremendously well
I was trying to go deeper but okay I'll
I'll take your word for it although you
could perhap s but how to modify that
idea by first going night takes Bishop
the night
and I involved in the attack so get rid
and that um yeah so your idea is that if
you've got this position you might be
able to play this that's right but
um but I was I was yes you were trying
to do it in a different move order
Knight takes B5 a b yep
about the G5 and now we get the same
same uh yeah again these three pawns if
I ever lose an exchange it's sort of
like enjoy yourself
enjoy your ears
no Bishop D2 was played Bishop D2 was
played it made sense you know why go
into it right and it does invite the
move Knight B2 and it does invite also
what we thought was the consequent play
of captures and
this is just tough to assess it's so
difficult such a crazy position right
right
very imbalanced right and what I'm
worried about array even though right in
time travel they're kind of synonymous
we know that whenever Ray plays Ray is
going to be in time travel but with this
type of position and with this type of
opponent being down to your last final
minute with your opponent having let's
say 5-10 minutes on the clock in a crazy
position that's going to be a death
sentence right in this game so he has to
be very careful about that aspect of
this matchup
at all easy
being uh
how do you say a fair-minded person
let's go to my pick Wesley
versus Segway
uh well we left it we left it after the
move Knight takes D5 Rook E1 and Sam did
not go for the C3 Pawn he's going for
the D3 Pawn as he should have he played
the move Knight F4
Queen to A4 tickling go ahead capture my
Pawn I'll capture your knight
Queen D7 Rook D1
my gosh you can just feel the pressure
for like both both players are playing
poker and they keep upping the ante with
each of their moves that they've been
playing Rook B5 Queen E4 Rook takes and
does this not invite the move Knight C4
I wanted to ask yes that movie was
crying out to be played like please
coach get me into the game uh the move
Knight C4 tickles The Rook definitely
hits this Pawn on E5 as well and it also
has another benefit of Simply defending
the pawn on D3 against the Knight and
the queen so Knight C4 is going to come
with Tempo I'm assuming it's Rook D5
yeah this whole time I mean and then
I'll win back the pawn Knight takes
Knight takes and how
my
instinctive reaction is that I like
white because I see this Knight as being
anchored and I don't see this Knight as
being anchored G5 is not the type of
move that you want to play so for
example I don't know where you can put
your queen queen to E7 excellent choice
and I'll play D4
so I mean
I I just in my mind I'm just making the
comparison of the two nights and that's
why I'm favoring why maybe not by a
whole lot but
Wesley's got
the upper hand yeah I unless we're doing
something wrong
I mean maybe there's a compensation of
the time uh I mean he's behind by what
30 minutes or so as we look at the
clocks there but Knight C4 and he's
taking his time as if he's got an
alternative he he does yeah really what
is that Knight C4 is not the best movie
no kidding yeah wow because after Knight
to C4 we were and this is very typical
of a human consider just Rook to D5 keep
contact with the pawn on E5 and maybe
increase the pressure on D3 but what
black should do right now is to actually
transfer The Rook via A2 A2 rooked way
to activate the Rook like that and
coupled it with the action of The Rook
on f8 so whenever the Knight leaves the
square F3 you're probably going to take
only five we take you take back now I go
Queen to D5
and we see this position if you take on
D5 I take back with the Knight and
suddenly I have coordinated double
threat yeah I'm attacking the pawn on C3
and the pawn on F2 so now we understand
why it's important to stay active in the
position as black with this move Rook to
A2 I have a feeling right now Wesley is
looking at this position and is thinking
how do I pull the brakes how do I make a
draw quiet the position down Play Moves
such as G3 perhaps G3 which was wait
without uh Knight C4 he did play that's
the best move in the position and he
found it
T3
wow I mean I think in a Blitz game it's
it's so hard to stop your hand from
playing the move Knight C4 in a
classical game you you reflect and you
say well wait a minute maybe I'm driving
The Rook as you've explained it
Christian to a much stronger Square Rook
A2 and I don't want to do that so let me
get rid of the Knight first
a good idea good idea
is something I always preach yeah get
out of your opponent's active piece G3
okay so let's just uh okay I mean Knight
takes d3's got to be wrong on all kinds
of uh there's gonna be some pin and win
you know once the White Knight moves out
of the way but is that true I mean I
I've got to ask I'm sorry I've just got
to ask if this works right I will no
longer believe anything in that okay
right
um
the night um moves so I'm thinking like
B3 hey you know I'm gonna attack
everything you got it and then after him
Rook takes Knight
Rook takes night and then Knight C5
gotcha but still there's Queen D5 at the
end of it
you you
you've done really well you've uh forked
my queen you hit my rook and
sorry for it
can we try it in a different way okay so
let's start with Knight to C4
okay uh instead of the Knight B3 I liked
your idea of Knight to C5 by the way I
mean it's a Pity that it came up so
short but and the same idea okay c35
uh
protection there we have it okay now
we're talking now there's nothing one
thing about Sam he's really playing fast
in this position he's not really
spending a lot of time pondering his
options
I think at a certain moment Sam
you know realize that one of the things
that was holding him back from really
great successes was the fact he was
getting into time trouble and that he
witnessed players like Wesley so
exploiting some of the best players in
the world thanks to the extra amount of
time he had on his clock and Sam just
decided screw that from now on I'm going
to play a lot faster and he has been
making uh steady progress there you see
what he's achieved and
one thing that's really helped his chest
obviously is actually reaching the
heights of being over 2700 because no
you know once you break that barrier
down you're no longer scrapping in these
big opens you're invited to tournaments
you can relax a little bit
exactly and um when he wasn't doing that
you know if he put a lot of value on
every single points and he did actually
say he's been working very very hard on
rapid kind of time controls right but I
have to say one thing about Sam you know
is just from observing him playing in
his Armageddon chess format a chess
format where they actually monitored the
heart rates he's very calm really yeah
and his heart resting heart rate was
roughly around about 80
which is which is normal which is very
good at the board
when he got tremendous yeah but when he
did get on under time time pressure
sorry
um it did rate issued up to 120 which
actually on the big scheme of things
wasn't that bad right but you could see
he was flustered whereas Wesley
um was playing and he started off with a
kind of a heart rate of 130 120 which is
quite High to begin the game with but
then it shot up to 170 at those critical
moments
but still Wesley kept his calm and he
was not flustered at all and in fact he
was completely shocked when we turned
around he got a personal you know record
he got 177 and he was like oh I'm
surprised because I did not feel
stressed right 95 the best movie in the
position wow to keep your
demeanor to keep your composure under
that kind of stress that's pretty
impressive uh 170 so wow you said G3
Rook uh pardon me Knight D5 uh by Sam
and I again uh just to a shout out to
Sam shankland uh we were having dinner
at the opening ceremony he was one of
the people at my table
I said Sam what have you been up to he
said yes sir it's it's been
hellacious I did I put the financing
touches on my rook and pawn in-game book
and it was like Wow and he says it's
been on my mind for months and months
and months and
I just got to share with you two of the
most remarkable full positions and
everybody with you know chess players
you know like they're listening in on
every car and he he told us two
positions that this Rook upon ending
book is focused upon which are just
crazy now it's sort of like
um Mutual zuk zwang has been accepted
term but you know it's really so rare
but in these rook and pawn end games he
found an enormous number Mutual six one
so it's promising to be a very good book
alert G3 Knight D5 Knight takes E5 Queen
takes E5 on the board this is the
position and what are the clock times
again uh we we think Wesley is a little
bit behind these last 22 minutes and Sam
with 54 minutes big difference how do we
assess the position I'm looking and I'm
seeing a better structure for white if
white could get his grips on the
position something like well first of
all the pawn on E6 is hanging but you
know what I mean you know something like
94 by the way C4 on tap there is a
potential pin what's the recommended
move here Christian you have a very
compact Pawn structure that's why yes
black has so many weaknesses exactly so
Rook 283 was played uh it's already on
the board okay it's one of the top moves
in the position and once again it does
seem like the strategy is for Sam to put
as much pressure on his opponent's clock
as well okay so this is what he's doing
go to A3 Knight to E4 is going to come
very logical move yes and by the way at
Knight E4 has maybe a kind of a deadly
threat of Knight C5 Knight takes E6 for
this reason what the engine was
recommending was actually to go Rook to
A2 first as before increase the pressure
on F2 Knight to E4 and now continue with
that pattern by playing the move Queen
to F7 right
now I have a threat I'm threatening take
on F2 and make a draw correct give you a
Perpetual so for example if you go
something like Rook to A1 let's say yeah
now I go Rook takes F2
take I take
perhaps I have more but I don't think so
okay
so this is what most likely would have
transpired if he would have found this
idea worked way too he decide against it
with Rook 283 still not bad but maybe if
white gets to stabilize the position
he's going to be able to make use of his
better structure so this is what I'm
keeping my eyes on right now will Wesley
be able to stabilize the position as is
and maybe reinforce the defense on the
second rank put the Rook on D2 or Rook
on E2 something along those lines Jovi
you've got some skin in the game between
Hikaru and Sam Sabian and guess what
they went right into that double Pawn
ending with C5 he's gonna say we are the
new fortune tellers
indeed Rook V8 Rook F2 okay we were
playing around a little bit with Rook D2
but Rook F2 will certainly work and
we're up to date with the players at
this exact moment and uh
well okay I like White's structure as
well I just don't know
if it's big if it's an advantage that we
can really uh say you know like this is
this is great stuff or not I meant I
think it's all going to come down to
whether black can launch an effective
defense over the C6 Pawn right and I
think for that the King has to make a
dash for the Santa
all right well we will make a dash for a
commercial break and we're going to see
you on the other side
thank you
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of Hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's a sound of personalized health care
and active communities it sounds like
life
that's what you hear when you really
listen
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in St Louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from laumeyer Sculpture Park and the
city garden to the stunning Cathedral
Basilica one of the largest Mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing St Louis is on
display all year long ooh now that's an
exhibit
St Lou is always exploring the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85 000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign
um
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you thank you
[Music]
welcome back and there's been a lot of
action so far in day one of the American
Cup yes there has uh Jovi and I'm really
impressed I I by the move of Sam
Shanklin I just didn't see it after the
move Rook A3 I saw the move 94 for
Wesley and I began to think oh Wesley
has got his grip on he's about to play
Knight C5 followed by Knight takes E6
and and Sam shanklin's position would
fall apart Sam recognized that and he
pulled the trigger on this very nice
move it just I I was blind uh to it and
after Knight takes C3 Knight takes C3
Rook F5 and looky looky there's no way
to defend the Knight on C3 all the
pieces came off the board and we're
we're now looking at a very equal rook
and pawn ending I would expect the game
to end rather shortly we do have Rook E1
on the board and so three versus three
and uh what a nice save there uh by Sam
Shanklin the move Knight C3 very nice I
looked at the game of Hikaru Nakamura
versus Sam sevillion and we had two sets
of double pawns a moment ago but now
we've got the triple pawns so we got a
trip upon double bond I mean that's
probably one of the worst Pawn
structures
how many porn Islands right one two
three four Pawn islands versus two so
Hikaru really got the concept the pawn
Islands down to Port Islands I thought
double pawns that aren't connected at
all like this guy like these guys yeah
they're the count for their own Port
Island yes yeah so those two are like
there's three on that side and four on
that side oh I see so you're thinking
that if you just had a double pawns you
would have two Pawn items yeah it's like
like if there was a Pawn on B7 then
that's going to connect the whole lot
I've never made that connection I've
always thought of the this is Apon
Island and these three guys are a pawn
Island but you would look at it and you
would say there's four four on the queen
side they're not holding hands they're
not holding hands
well uh to uh crib the planet of the
eight yes pawns together stronger right
they're not holding hands
uh that is true uh how bad is it how
good is it we don't know but Christian
uh you you explain uh about the pawn
islands are they four on the queen side
or two
upon Islands on the queen side I would
say there are two Pawn Islands on the
green side two two Pawn Islands right
yeah well I mean Jovi had four total no
that four total for black total for
white two on the queen side for black
that's that at least that's my reap
right in the position well I mean she's
coming from the United Kingdom
we have different measurements you know
I haven't studied that one yet very good
how do you assess the position how do
ISS doesn't really matter that much
because you guys have analyzed it quite
deeply but how does the engine assess
this there you go it says that white is
very close to winning wow in this
position after the move Rook to D7
Rook to D6 I pick up this pawn and how
do you continue I'm seeing a very active
Rook on the seventh rank I see a lot of
weaknesses in Black's position how do
you continue as black try to stay in the
gate I like the move C4 I mean C4 right
now yeah do you get ready with King G7
maybe get out from any of the checks on
the back rank I wanted or do you just go
C4 yeah I wanted to stop B3 so yeah
exactly I think that's a critical thing
okay okay stop B3 let's keep going let's
keep going so so I'm activating my king
okay
um King G7 makes a lot of sense right
yeah Fair yeah when I'm starting I'm
starting to tickle you a little can we
not maximize first before we dance
around with the Rooks I'm thinking of
pushing pawns because that's my favorite
thing on the king size as white yeah
yeah you can definitely do that yes H4
is is a perfectly viable option right
now you do have to be sort of attentive
uh this idea of F5 and maybe it's
changing more pawns right
um I'm thinking if that's the case maybe
I can go g for try to stop at this pawn
and cement the pawn on F6 maybe get a
nice Square for my king on F4 that's an
idea now Rook to A7 A5 and yes G4 seems
to be the best move King to E3 as well
is a very good move
look
the material is limited one bad move and
you're going to lose your advantage as
white so Hikaru still has to be very
careful nevertheless it does seem uh
that this position is just much better
for him and we're playing for two
results at this point and we've been
playing for two results since that trade
on C6 at least in my estimation
um it's either a Hikaru win or a draw
Sam is on the defensive and he's going
to show his defensive prowess to survive
in this game all right very good I just
want to turn quickly before we go to the
ladies game uh ladies uh matches uh I'm
looking at the game between Fabi and Rey
they did follow the line to Queen D7 I
didn't know what white was supposed to
do Fabi played the move Rook B1 and the
more you look at that move you say well
yeah obviously that's a that's a really
fine move it stops night from coming to
B2 and it asks Rey what he wants to do
in the position he dropped back with the
Knight Bishop G5 takes takes Queen takes
D5 I'm anticipating Knight takes
uh Pawn takes Rook takes and maybe white
has a smidge of something going here
I'll no Queen takes F3 Queen
no followed by Knight to A4
where's your Edge
I thought the Knight had to go backwards
and that was uh where I got mistaken
just make a draw you go okay five take
on C3 take on C5 and we just I'm going
to take on C4 at some point as well
this this seems like a very uh
straightforward draw
wow nothing to be done here huh no no no
no no we're just sweeping all the pieces
off the board I just I I'm not trapping
the night somehow no yes or don't don't
get greedy
and we do have a handshake our first
result of the American Cup draw
I have to say a very complex draw
between these two players yeah it wasn't
an easy game
and uh well that means for tomorrow
they'll switch colors they will switch
colors and there will be everything to
play for because whoever wins in that
match tomorrow tomorrow we'll move on to
the championship brackets
yeah should they draw then uh it will go
to tie breaks immediately immediately
right and they will play a rapid
format of 10 minutes yes plus extra time
I think right five well actually hold on
wasn't it uh it was a little bit slower
than that and then they go to the blitz
so yesterday they had they had the rules
and regulations they're all very very
nicely posted on the website and arbiter
Chris bird kind of came on and said you
know like we ought to play and instead
of just two Rapids and move to
Armageddon we ought to play two Blitz
and so they snuck in uh an extra set of
two games of Blitz but you're right it
is games it is gave 10 minutes
and then this this is where the big
addition happened you know if that match
is still tied then we have another
two-game Blitz playoff will be three
minutes plus two second increment and if
the match is still tied after all those
games then it will go down to the crowd
favorite
Armageddon where white will get five
minutes and black will get four minutes
on the clock but gets draw odds and the
loser of this playoffs
they go to the elimination bracket and
whereupon they will start playing at 25
minutes and I think at the Players
meeting they also made a slight tweak to
that final graphic of the Armageddon my
understanding was in the Armageddon they
play five minutes to four minutes stop
until they get to move 60 once they get
thrust move 61 or on move 61 I think the
players are getting uh two seconds
absolutely and this was the same case
last year and I remember there was this
um nail biting finish in the game
between Fabiano caruana and Jeffrey
Zhong because they went to Armageddon
and I think Jeffrey just had to make I
think two Moves In Like A few seconds
and he didn't do it and Fabiana carono
won in a couple completely lost position
yeah very painful very painful indeed
just jumping to the ladies uh looking at
the game between Anna and Naji for just
a moment because uh we kind of let this
game go underneath our radar it was one
of those isolated Queen Pawn
um Queens Gambit accepted type of games
and we've got
um getting I'm now I believe with this
last move Knight to D3 up to date now
Anna zatonski she's got a reputation
like Ray Robson of enjoying time trouble
what are the clocks between these two
players what are they looking like well
you're quite uh Anna has 15 minutes yep
and Nashi has 33 minutes okay two to one
time advantage and what do we think of
the position do you like playing against
the isolated Queen Pawn or do you prefer
uh
I love playing against isolated
but I I don't I love them but at the
same time I don't necessarily enjoy them
I enjoy the prospect of winning winning
in the in the long term in the end game
uh when it comes to this type of
positions where the minor pieces are
very much on the board I mean every
single move
requires some degree of accuracy because
you're calculating you know for tricks
look at Black's pieces I mean they are
ready to spring forward so ideas that
you know black has in their pocket is
obviously Bishop H3 you can't quite do
that now I understand there's also
Knight takes porn sacrifices that you
need to calculate also you need to
invest some time into ideas such as
building the position up like The Rook
coming to d8 and then black threatens D
fight D4 D sorry D5 D4 and there's so
much play it's very difficult to get a
kind of handle on this type of Dynamics
for me the the idea of isolated queen
palms were very very simple I liked
playing against them when there weren't
a lot of minor pieces on the board when
they're when the minor P when when the
board is full of minor pieces I like
playing with the isolated creep part so
in this particular moment I would say I
I would favor playing Black I like
narji's position after the move Rook d8
but uh Christian I'm going to turn to
you because I think we have a guess we
do have a guest indeed we are here with
Sam Shanklin after a comfortable draw
against Wesley so Sam welcome to the
studio tell us a bit about your trip to
Berlin you just came back from Berlin
where you actually met Wesley in the
finals yeah so uh definitely that match
probably gave him more confidence coming
into this one than it gave me but yeah
it was fun to play Blitz there I I've
always focused so much more on classical
chess than Blitzen anyway and I
definitely that's you know in classical
chess I'm really one of the best players
in the world and in Blitz not so much
but I was very happy that in Berlin I
finished in second place so yeah I got
out of a bunch of really strong guys and
uh managed to beat the streamers who
always crushed me on line so uh yeah
getting to play over the board felt good
but yeah glad to be back here now how do
you change that training routine because
we know you focus a lot on very
difficult problems where you get to
spend a lot of time and find the
solution how do you change your training
not just that I mean I also go deep into
like Rook end games I've just finished
first draft of my book theoretical Rook
hand games which is an absolute Behemoth
can I go deep opening preparation too I
mean Blitz basically you just have to
play a whole ton of games and you have
to be born talented while classical it's
a bit more fair and that you put in the
hours you're going to get better
um but yeah I just you know play a
little bit more Blitz and I mean it's
still definitely not my main focus or
anything but yeah I'm very glad to be
playing classical chess again I haven't
played since us championship and glad to
get invited to tournament here I'll
throw you a curveball what do you think
of this end game
between Hikaru and Sam Seville speaking
of rook and games very likely a draw I
think I mean white we won one Pond but I
don't think you're going to win this
game like uh for example if you do
something like say B3 which because I
don't know what else B3 right yeah okay
after cb3 ab3 Rook B3 Rook C6 take take
and King G7 and Rook S6 actually it's
significantly easier to draw this with
black with the fractured Pawn structure
than it is with the normal one although
even the normal one I can't imagine
sylvian's gonna lose so I mean if akari
wants to win this game he's not going to
play B3 but I mean it really feels like
black should be holding it
um unless yeah unless I can somehow get
his maneuver his C7 Rook to C3 somehow
which I just don't see happening either
I definitely think this should be a draw
and yeah looks very holdable to me
excellent now let's talk about your game
tell us the story of that
I got a very comfortable open very
quickly I think so if you actually go
back to instead of Bishop A4 let's say
he plays the Italian
let's say he plays Bishop C4 Bishop C5
uh like uh C3 and Knight F6 D3 Castle
whatever
um yeah D3 castle castle I mean forget
the move it doesn't matter like D6 H3 uh
A6
A4 there exists a move B5 in this
position I don't know if it's exactly
here but like
before then if you take oh no sorry
especially seven first another night The
Specialist I've been working one and
then be five yeah so here there there
exists rookie one there exists this move
B5 which Arya antari played with me and
the best move is probably Bishop B3 and
I think black is basically fine here
after B4 and then the game I just got
this with the tempo up because he's
played Bishop B5 Bishop A4 Bishop B3
instead of Bishop C4 Bishop B3 and even
here I thought black was basically fine
so like I got a Tempo up version of this
Italian the way we got it
uh yeah like here yeah because you're
after a B4 Lake he's taking three moves
to put the bishop me through so I got
this very comfortable position pretty
fast but I tried a little too hard to
make something happen like when um when
I played D5 I think is critical like I
mean
because this is obviously a somewhat
controversial move because now if we can
see if I've found no is trying to to
make something happen but I think I
overestimated my position a little bit
because it got a little uncomfortable
after 85 and then it takes D5 but you're
still playing so confidently at this
point yeah like you calculated that I
was never super worried like okay for
example after rookie one Knight F4 is
played I mean it's tough it was a little
uncomfortable here but I really didn't
think it was much like Queen F4 Queen D5
and okay our Queen D7 they were instead
of Rook I do one he could have tried for
example there was D4 here for instance
which was at least a little bit
concerned about but I thought that
basically anything was fine I think in
the game I was actually thinking even
Rook fd8 which the computer apparently
hates but uh G3 this one messed up okay
well well I would have thought here but
yeah I mean this looked a little
uncomfortable but I didn't really see a
huge problem like it felt like babe it
was basically fine and after Queen E4 I
think
I basically calculated out all the way
till the end of the game and then
I saw this Knight takes C3 move because
without that it's probably a little
uncomfortable but yeah or a lot
uncomfortable yeah I'd seen this from
afar and yeah
Sam uh pretty comfortable draw tomorrow
you play with the white pieces what's
the strategy well do my best to put him
under pressure I mean Wesley is
definitely the most solid guy in this
tournament you know he's
probably not the most dangerous but he's
definitely the hardest one to beat so
you know I will do my best to put him
under pressure but you know I've I've
gotten it's very rare that I've been
able to get advantages of white against
someone I have he always holds it so it
and I'll I'll do my best but uh yeah the
hard game is behind me I guess so far so
good difficult task tomorrow good luck
thank you thank you Sam indeed uh
difficult test tomorrow all the games
are difficult uh jumping uh back to the
game that we had our eye on which was
the game between Annie Anna satonski and
Naji I think Anna understood what we
were talking about in terms of minor
pieces uh coming off the board so she
tried to move Knight E5 in order to
trade some of the pieces off the board
and now you correctly in my view said
well okay we can trade but definitely
we're gonna trade on my terms you want
to take the Knight on C6 feel free
Knight take C6 I will take with the pawn
and um I'll be a happy camper as I no
longer have to suffer an isolated Pawn
so I still you know you don't want to
you don't wanna you don't want to play
F4 certainly not with the bishop on B6
but uh
it's it feels like there's something in
the right because I mean suddenly
there's the possibility of Knight takes
F2 I mean and let's not also forget the
Tactical points after Bishop H3 as well
right so
um but the main point of concern is is
Knight takes F2 exact problem if it is a
problem then okay I I would probably
want to bring my knight on B5 I There's
Something About This diagonal that
really bothers me and the idea of
closing the diagonal by sticking a
knight on D4 that would definitely have
my uh attention and we're going to go
back to Christian with another guest in
studio Christian we are indeed with a
Wesley so Wesley I'm going to ask you a
similar question to what I asked Sam you
came back from Berlin you did have a
match in the finals against Sam Shanklin
you won that yeah how do you feel that
impacts this particular match
uh well it doesn't really
change too many things the time
controller is very different I mean I'm
very happy to win the tournament in
Berlin the Armageddon series but at the
same time
control was very fast and the games were
very short I only play two two games
mini match and uh I only played eight
games in total so it's not a big deal I
mean it's
um my main focus is classical chess
although I don't seem to be doing well
but in this day and age you can need to
be good at all time controls so it's
nice that I can do well here and there
and that's very surprising to me because
you did so well in the global Chess
Championship you won that you just won
in Berlin as well it does feel like you
feel very comfortable in Rapid and Blitz
setups yeah it seems to be the case uh
after the pandemic I've been practicing
a lot online I've been trying a lot of
different mouths
so the mechanics also are very important
right yeah it's very different playing
over the board than playing online
actually in Berlin I was sparring with
some other players there over the board
just because
playing on computer and a tablet it's
very very different and I've been
playing a lot online but um
yeah at the same time my results in the
classical been fairly a bit
disappointing so my reading right now is
around 27 60 I've been trying for a
couple years trying to get it up to like
2780 to 790 but
uh I'm struggling a little bit so I'm
working on stuff and uh trying to
improve uh it's I'm very grateful that
St Louis is putting tournaments uh like
here in the American Cup we have eight
of the best players in the country
then we have grantchester coming up in
Romania so I'm very excited uh for that
speaking of this match and tomorrow's
game with the black pieces what is your
strategy for that one are you going to
try to neutralize or are you going to
take more risks with the black pieces
what is the strategy well I probably
shouldn't say too much
time could be listening but I you know
just uh in a 2 game mini match you can't
really afford to make too many mistakes
so I just want to
give my best you know and see where it
leads try to play the best moves uh
today he surprised me in the opening I
thought he would lead the Sicilian like
he was playing in the Berlin but Sam's
very unpredictable
and he knows a lot like I've never seen
this move
on the eight more Bishop A7 before
yeah so I mean white Black Ops 3 other
main moves but B8 Bishop G4 yeah
blade Bishop A7 and it looks a little
bit obvious but at the same time I
didn't really know exactly what the best
ways to play without risking too much
um
and you were also spending a lot of time
in the opening phase but also in the
middle game phase he was building up
quite a substantial time Advantage did
you feel any pressure coming from that
yeah for sure that's why in the end I
was you know trying to play the most
logical moves uh
because one thing to note here is that
you don't get extra time after move 40
so it's very very different
um the but at the same time the
beginning you want to spend as much time
make sure not to make too many mistakes
not to make a blunder
by in the end I was speeding up but it
was definitely a struggling in terms of
time it affected some of my decisions
later on so that's one thing that could
be improved upon that at the same time
I'm a bit surprised that some
was playing very very quickly today so
maybe he didn't have to uh
he didn't have to find too many moves uh
over the board because like Bishop E6 is
simple
and also mostly moves like group B5
wasn't and Sam uh described you as one
of the toughest players to beat in this
tournament how would you describe Sam
yeah well that's very kind of him to say
I honestly don't think so but um
but I mean Sam is uh it's a fighter uh
he's a very hard working fellow you know
he's written several books back about
his most recent book in quality chess uh
I'm very impressed by his determination
by the fact that he always bounces back
I think his results could be very
unpredictable and his player sometimes
could be uh you know very
uh inconsistent but when he plays well
he's Unstoppable like I I've known him
for
about almost a decade now I think in
2014 I was working with him
for the chess Olympian in fact he won a
gold medal
for his individual board yep about five
so that was very impressive he had nine
out of ten also in the US championships
in 2018 that's one of the best
performances ever
um so as
he keeps saying he puts a lot of effort
on his chess he's had several difficult
games and this is your lifetime you
actually never lost against him in
classical chess I actually had no idea
how to
you're doing quite well yeah I had no
idea I didn't even know I played him
that many games but
Wesley thank you thank you very much you
still have a game to play tomorrow and
maybe the playoffs after that so we let
you rest yeah we'll see you tomorrow
thank you Wesley good luck tomorrow I
wanted to turn quickly to the game
between Arena and Tata exactly at this
moment Arena made a very very long-term
decision she sacrificed a pawn and I'm
just wondering how deeply she calculated
it because it's a very impressive piece
of calculation indeed Bishop to E1
Knight to C5 Bishop to B1 take my Pawn
definitely she got here in her
calculation and there's a lot of moves
that tats have made they have have
looked at at this point Tata played the
move Rook E5 but after the move Knight
G3
black got into trouble very very quickly
Bishop to C6 F4 and this is huge this
move Knight H5 and it really
besets a black an enormous amount of
problems Bishop takes F6 and queen G4
signed my score sheet it's game over
Jovi after the move Knight D7 I think we
caught up to the players I was about to
say make a suggestion she did choose the
move Knight F5 I'm the pawn Grabber in
the family I just didn't see anything
wrong with Knight takes E6 as well I
thought that this was going to be
Advantage white I don't think you have a
better move than Rook E6 but she blink
G6 but you yeah said I like Knight F5
during the interview and why did you
like Knight F5 well it has a very
yeah I mean I was wondering here is is
Tattoo's idea Knight takes night and
then Bishop thanks to you
and then Knight to us to chat I can
think no this is just too much it's a
queen queen versus a rook
it's that you're not getting the minor
piece if you if you had Rook takes B8 on
the board I'm I'm with you at halfway
one which is going to allow you to be
just a piece down right that's not a joy
uh I'm actually a little bit surprised
that Knight G4 is Knight G4 like
completely necessary does F5 not
looks crunchy too doesn't it it looks
fantastic here um
three thumb snaps but Knight G4 should
be good enough too of course so irina's
uh winning but I always also told
Christian that Alice
Alice Lee is doing very well uh jump
over to your board she is break it down
but it's still very very complex and it
still requires uh a lot of precision
because you haven't won a single Pawn
you haven't won any material in the
position you did create some weaknesses
around the king side specifically after
this move H6 and G5 now I have this
extra Square for my knight on F5 and if
that couples uh with a potential Rook uh
entry on the seventh rank the King on H7
is going to start feeling feeble but
unfortunately I don't see the final blow
in the position so
sure white is better but black still has
her chances in the position and how are
we doing on time 11 minutes for atusa
verses 27 minutes for Alice Alice is
putting on the pressure in the position
nevertheless it's still not easy to
crack but let's take a look at what's
happening in the Anna zatonski versus
Naji paikidze right now because we have
this position and you guys were
mentioning Anna loves her time travel
situations and this is exactly where
she's headed
20 moves in and she only has 9 minutes
left on the board and I can take with
the p Pawn on C6 I can also take with
the Rook on a C6 of offer up the trade
of the Rooks look at how many attackers
I have aimed at your king queen on G5
the bishop potentially coming to H3 the
Knight very nicely centralized on e4 and
guess what this Rook is most likely
going to join The Fray as well for
example if you take take and then go
back to D4 I always have ideas of Rook
to D6 in the future I can start off with
taking on a D4 first you take back and
then I go Rook to D6 things of that
nature and just feels like I have so
many attackers against your king you
don't have as many Defenders around it
so by simple math it just tells me that
my attacks should be successful in this
instance Bishop to H3 Bishop to F3 Rook
to D6 and the game continues
nevertheless with so much pressure
piling on her and only nine minutes on
the clock I feel right now she's in an
emergency situation and as a task with
the white pieces that is
speaking of emergency situations uh I'll
jump back to the game of Arena versus
tata for just a moment because Irina did
choose the Knight G4 I thought F5 but
Knight G4 certainly there goes a queen
but after Bishop takes d8 instead of the
move Knight F2 which basically that
would have been just too grim this move
Knight E3 is much stronger the much
better chance you give up your queen for
two pieces because no I don't know
oh you just resigned I apologize if you
take from D1 I'll give you a check the
Intermezzo that's the best you can get
just a piece down okay well then it
resigns uh as soon as she sees Bishop
takes B6 you'll have to resign I'm
thinking you move the queen it doesn't
matter where you move the queen 68 yeah
and you know you've got two minor pieces
and a pawn and it's a game but no Bishop
takes B6 is game over sorry no I was I
was gonna say the same
um but I was just kind of also wanted to
have a look at irina's body language
whether she spotted it because Irene is
fantastic at calculation oh yes she she
supports all Alternatives and uh
she's just considering her options here
and there we can see her looked but one
of the things though instinctively you
do
we preserve the queen exactly yeah your
Queen's being attacked but then again
whenever your head material your
instinct is also to trade so you start
thinking to yourself well I can code
taking on B6 and taking on D1 and then
you see the Intermezzo Bishop takes C5
check and then your mind's made up in in
an instant because again after a move
like Queen D2 and yes I I am hanging The
Rook with the tempo uh just pointing out
that the minor pieces here are offering
a kind of a decent compensation
especially with the Knight on E3
and the bishop you know I wouldn't want
to be in White's shoes in this situation
so that's underneath we do what does she
play Bishop takes B yeah yeah and that's
game over an arena I mean the American
Cup is just
seriously last year she was super
impressive uh undefeated she she won and
something about this event really
appeals to her uh Christian not only
undefeated but I remember she had
absolutely no problems in any of her
games right she was never worse in any
of her games and with so many matches on
the line that's just simply impressive
and we see the first decisive result of
the American Cup Irina Crush picks it up
where she left it off last year and gets
a crucial Victory against abrahamian
and how about your pupil uh Christian uh
she's doing very very well begum's got
exactly a dream position of course from
the opening yes and she still has but
still there is that
um final blow and I see you got to
convert see it yet I don't see it yet
and she doesn't see it either she keeps
shuffling the pieces we see this queen
landing on G4 Dental H4 Knight to EA to
defend the pawn on D6 Rook to D7
Queen backs to G4 but what I do like
about the position is actually her time
expenditure right now she has 28 minutes
and her opponent with no second time uh
control coming right only four minutes
on her clock so definitely the pressure
is going to increase in this position
you don't have to speed things up you
don't have to open up the position you
don't have to play A3 and then B4 try to
go for some F4 break you can wait until
your opponent gets down to her last
minute and then find uh that clinical
blow and this is I think exactly what
she's doing right now and it doesn't
seem like black has a lot of options to
get out of that conundrum yeah that's
good strategy indeed I have to say when
your opponent is shows on time don't
make those forcing moves right just to
enjoy your position over protect every
single piece you have and then let them
just anticipate those unexpected moves
December the clock exactly
and so far we've had one decisive result
and we see Arena crash defeating tatev
abrahamian in a very convincing display
I have to say Arena was very impressive
definitely that whole Pond sacrifice uh
I would wonder how deeply she calculated
but that was very good I want to
emphasize that in Grand Master play uh
triple pawns are quite rare but did you
notice we got them again in the game
between Levon and Lanier and the triple
Pawns in this particular case that Lavon
has just a moment let me get this
position actually
very very useful and what lavonus is is
saying is these Pawns
are basically keeping the black Rook at
Bay they you just can't use any of the
squares on the e-file to all the
business squares as we would say are
covered in the meanwhile your extra Pawn
on the queen side is not being utilized
you haven't played you can't get a
candidate pollen with the move C5 and I
am just a move or two away from playing
H6 and Rook G7 doesn't mean I can break
through I'm not sure the triple pawns
are made yeah the problem the problem is
is that there is an open line on the
airline and that prevents the white king
from making a dash a dash sorry making
haste rushing to the C5 Square
um yeah so I think a kind of a key
question you've got to ask yourself is
if I do play the move King D6 and I do
threaten C5 is H6 too slow because I
think C5 is actually
good maybe I'll play Rook down in order
to
come come after the pawn on F6 I I don't
know what's going on I'll play C5 oh but
then the Rook can give a check true
favorite thing yes Rook D7 and well then
you take on with check I think we check
yes you take on check with C5 and make a
dash or D4 okay so let me change the
order I go King to C6 first no no it's
fine keep going C5 okay okay and now
after Rook to C8 I go Rook C7 right so
there's no more check
but there is
you can go Rook at fate yeah this is
also the question and now it becomes
some sort of a uh this is weird right
right I mean these are like the worst
pawns I've ever seen as far as racing
but these guys are the greatest either I
mean okay uh it's it's a funny business
what's going on here let's see about
Fabi and Ray just one second because
there is a very beautiful uh aspect of
this position for example after King to
D6 I think this was yeah you guys were
trying check this move out Rook to G6
I actually saw this like a split second
before so now I'm going to force you to
go Rook to F7 you cannot take on G6 if
you take on G6 I take with the F Pawn H6
H7 I'm going to Queen
you're just simply too far this was like
one of the breakthroughs I made as a
youngster when I discovered that two
pawns could be stronger than a rook I
mean it was really shocking to me that a
rook worth buy could be overwhelmed by
two pawns and you're right H6 H7
overwhelmed so I and they were very
dismissive of my beautiful pawns on the
f file but I am I was I will be
things you take on G6 check that out so
if you do take the Rook yes well I do
take with the F Pawn and you go Rook to
G7 to try to stop me from going H6 well
I have the F4 Pawn coming to F5 that's
it game over
it is
it is it is a very beautiful I'm not
talking about the pawn on S3 you can be
dismissive of that pawn on f3s yeah it
could be selective in my dismissal I
only care about the F5 and F4 I I you're
basically provoking Rook F7 and you
wanted to say in this case you could
maybe you don't have to I can start with
H6 and that's going to stop you from
going C5
because if your king goes too far away
I'm going to take that and then I'm
going to follow that with Rook to G7 and
but then also you can combine the white
king into the action right so you can
just leave your work on G6 for a long
time and then I was thinking if the king
steps back okay
run with the King to E2
it's strange to see a a player
dominating a rook and pawn end game with
triple pawns I mean I can understand you
know what player dominating a position
when they have a lot of space and I've
got pawns on G by then F6 and and your
pawns are on B6 and A6 so how about the
G6 move right now so C5 was played take
on C5 King to C6
so oh pardon me on the board C5 was
played C5 immediately was played yes
and the idea was after takes now King to
C6 and now once again you're suggesting
Rook to G6 why not why not let's go for
that pawn by the way uh I will calculate
this I want to say once again that at
four o'clock uh Gary Kasparov is coming
online and in the name in the meanwhile
we have a guest in studio do we we do
have in yeah that's what I thought
with Grandmaster Irina Crush Irina you
picked it up where you left it last year
with dominant Victory how do you feel
right now yeah I feel pretty good about
this game I feel like you know I got a
playable position from the opening
something that I was at least interested
by and
um and probably the most interesting
moment was when I've sacked the pawn or
at least I you know I offered that E3
Pawn up and that was at uh which move
yeah it's coming up shortly yes right
here oh yeah so when I was playing
Bishop E1 yeah so I was like you know
the whole theme of this position is kind
of Peace Improvement right so my Bishop
on D2 is not the best I moved him to E1
to have you know the idea of Bishop H4
and and I was thinking you know yeah if
black plays Knight C5 of course I can
play Bishop F2 or I can play Bishop B4
um but ultimately yeah I thought well
you know the Knight went there to take
my Bishop I don't really like to give up
Bishops you know
um so Bishop B1 seemed like a reasonable
Pawn sack because E3 Pawn is weak and um
as long as my king is on H1 I don't
really mind losing it all my pieces get
to be on really good squares I would say
like in this position you know the Rook
on eight is still not in the game the
knights on C5 a bit awkward bishop and
D7 is restricted so I just thought like
well this is did you feel like you have
enough speed for your attack right now I
I thought this this is what is called
compensation in chess right like if this
is a compensation that I don't know what
it is yeah and you played Bishop to H4
Rook to E5 and by the way she was
spending a lot of time did that play
into your consideration to give up the
pawn just because she was getting no no
I think that's that was really just my
chest understanding give up Pawn I would
have done that pretty much in any
scenario but certainly it made things
harder for her to defend you know a
position where white has the initiative
and and then you have no time and
honestly I never saw anything like very
convincing for black I mean okay it was
not my job to solve all of Black's
problems but really I didn't see
something you know I mean I felt like
she her um her attempts were not quite
gonna do it but I didn't know what was
going to save black in this position yep
and that's exactly what happened all of
your pieces were just swarming around
her King and this pin was so difficult
to get oh yeah
yeah you know I have a video on my
YouTube channel that I recently started
called pins are dangerous so I guess you
know um yeah this will be example number
two excellent excellent Knight to D7
Knight to F5 and after that you just
broke through and you finished yeah I
noticed there was going to be a little
check here actually I'll just show at
the end after if she takes my queen uh
the key point is that there's Bishop C5
check and then I was still trying to
evaluate this position because I was
like well rook cd1 and then Pawn D4
opening the bishop with rookie two ideas
and here I was just thinking you know
maybe just Bishop D3 just like don't
mess around and don't let rookie two
happen and eventually okay the dark
squared Bishop should that's be decisive
probably the smart decision in this
position Arena there's something about
the American Cup it just feels like you
were coming with extra motivation but
also a lot of confidence do you feel
that way as well well you know it's
interesting it's only the second time
around it's hard to say
um but I mean I feel good about this
tournament I'm happy to be here I'm
always happy to be in Louis
and I do like this format it's a very
unique format I don't get to play
anything else like that that's kind of
match format I mean the only other thing
is like a world championship knockout
something like that that I've played in
before but that's the that's kind of um
maybe it doesn't give you any second
chances like this one does
um although I'll try not to not to need
Second Chances you know as much as
possible and um yeah just happy to be
here and that's exactly what you did
last year congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you Christian absolutely
uh thank you Irina congratulations
indeed just uh breaking news by the way
Gary has pushed back his interview until
4 40 apologies for that as we see our
Champions bracket with one result
yeah so tomorrow
unless tartev actually wins then it will
be Arena moving on to the Champions
bracket and tadev will go down to the
elimination bracket exactly turning our
attention to Alice Elise game for just a
quick second uh she did manage to win
upon it's one of those four versus uh
three on the king side but the addition
of the extra Pawn on the queen side
really very very much improves White's
chances of winning this position and I
don't know how would you have I would
see this as a near 75 percent chance of
winning uh is that am I overstating
Alice's position what do you think do
you think that this is a a position
that's closer to a draw than a win or
how do you how do you uh calculate
you're asking the queen of overstatement
two percentages I'm I'm with you like 75
and um everyone
I feel like it's I mean again you take
these a pawns off the board I'm saying
draw okay just draw but the fact that
they're on the board and black has to
constantly uh
deal with that but I actually feel that
this please help me it does in this
instance if we would see the white Rook
on the a file and the black Rook
defending passively on the seventh rank
then I would say that the position is
winning but since I see the black Rook
on A6 putting pressure dominating The
Rook on C3 and potentially going to A4
and then supporting the move F5 later on
in the future try to eliminate more
pawns on the king side I just feel like
black is very very close to equalizing
this all right I'm surprised at that
because I actually just had it in my
mind that the white king would rush to
the rescue of the airport yeah right
Rush
before and I will create my own chances
uh I'm okay I've got a question King E3
is kind of what you're saying uh Jovi
Alice is thinking that she's dashing
over to the A3 phone I was going the
other way she went Central I went
kingside I really wanted to get in the
move H4 myself and I thought that if you
play H4 for example we'll just put this
with some moves on the board this I move
prepares F5 and I think uh White is the
one who is doing really the moment you
play Rook takes A3 I'm going to play E5
right and I love this kind of standoff I
think that this favors white I hear what
you saying they're a Christian about The
Rook on the a file pressuring A3 as
being favorable but I'm thinking uh Paul
karez Michael badvinic where the Rooks
ended up
uh being passive for Paris and he ended
up losing a crucial game and that's
probably why I wouldn't go H4 so if we
go back a couple of moves maybe try to
use that go Rook to A4 and if I go H5 if
you do go H4 yeah so you're saying that
if I go G4 you're going to get this
beautiful Square on F4 for the key
precisely that's that's beautiful and
that's probably deadly for me right I
don't want to allow you to get there so
after H4
maybe I can start with F6 can I do that
uh H4 check King G4S
you play H4 and also F6
yes
and how do we feel about that well I
feel like made progress I've traded an
H2 Pawn for a G5 pawn and fair enough
absolutely I I will take with the King
you'll take I don't think I want to
allow you to get that past Pawn on on
the e-file but I mean isn't this a
situation where you can switch tactic
and yeah I was actually thinking of
driving the king back and then going for
the H Pawn Yeah something like this well
I
and now I wait
I don't know exactly how but I wait
let's say Rook to C4
ah Now you kind of released me Please
Release Me Not Yet right
but now don't I have F5 perhaps wow no
F5 you're playing with fire G3 check is
uh on my agenda you're right I I just
have to wait rooked way for let's
continue waiting
wow okay so now I'm I'm you've maximized
right but how do you deliver that that
final blow exactly okay let's just go go
Steady As She Goes my next move is I'm
going to play E5 and I'm going to take
with the rook and bring my Rook to G5
with a check so
fair enough G3 I was just saying that
that Alice made the determination right
here to go with her King to the center
and it felt more natural to go King G3
and H4 King F3 Rook B6 on the board and
again how do we
feel about this because this one more is
more frightening I'm thinking that if if
black gets this type of counter play
with Rook B2
Alice's chances of winning go well what
I do know is that
Sam Shanklin has a lot of material for a
potential edit because
we have so many Rook m games this is one
of them right check the open section
check hikaru's game but also Levon
against uh Dominguez that's a big one
and we're reaching the boiling point in
that one actually what happened after
King C6 we left it at this point H6 King
takes Rook G6 yes borrowing a page from
what you had suggested a moment ago Rook
G6 now it's very important that you
don't play Rook F7 Rook F7 would have
disaster written all over it after the
move Rook G7 the H Pawn is going to
become a passer
but Lanier recognizing that said you're
welcome to munch my F6 Pawn
what and he's playing the best moves
on his clock wow look to B7
not allowing the white Rook to go to B6
wow that is a hidden move that's a gem
of a movement actually that's beautiful
wow I'm telling you Sam is going to take
notes after this run I mean because
again you know you could go Rook down
and you could push your Pawn all the way
to F7 and think you're making progress
but you just come to a dead end I'll go
King B3 King takes B2 and it feels like
black one actually actually it's not it
feels like it it could be winning for
black right what would you give to get
to have one of those babies on the f
file
exactly exactly just you know could you
could you kind of switch and I'll go
back to the original plan and put the
Rook on G6
G7 that's yeah yeah that's a fair fair
point yeah okay it becomes a race
but who's faster and why right
so I take this one and now I now
probably you should go for the h8 right
well you gotta if you move your Rook to
the a file which maybe you would like to
do
H7 and F6 but now I go B4 right it's
just a race
and who gets there first with the most
well I think you gave me a an extra
Tempo by taking on B4 oh I apologize yes
you're right I sure did I played B4 and
I should have played H7 yes H7 Rook H6
probably you have to play right now F6
F6 and then I oh my goodness well let me
go Rook here pardon me
of this move as well that's beautiful
because now F6 doesn't come with F7 if
I've gone Rook H6 what you were about to
propose then your F6 moved is it killer
F6 you go F6
let's see if I can trick you right now
okay yes I did nice F7 thank you I treat
you
who what what who who what okay f8 f8
and maybe it's a draw yeah
just a draw actually no I think this is
winning Queen to F6 I trade the Queens
could be and then you go then I go okay
yeah okay and I think that finally my
two pawns are actually going to do this
you you tricked me but you tricked me in
a very nice way so should I have played
the movie yes you have to hide the king
from any chance
right wow
um
and this still could be this could turn
into Black's favor too I mean those
yeah I don't know what's happening in
this piece this is not something that
you you feel definitely secure about but
let me just apologies I'm just going to
refresh the board for just a quick
moment to get the current position Rook
B7 and again I think this is a gem of a
move uh it's very very easy to miss that
this source of counter play what I was
expecting Lanier to do and probably it
would have been wrong was somehow to
utilize the d-pawn as of as the powerful
Pawn but there's always Rook E6 and the
d-pawn's going nowhere I mean after the
move Rook E6 but this move Rook B7
that's really
wow that's sweet okay now having said
that let's see this line because there's
another way of
but check this one check this position
yeah sure just to show you how beautiful
and how difficult rook and games are in
this position after King takes C5 he
played the move Rook to G6 right but
what you can do you can start with the
move Rook to G7 okay Force the king back
first that's going to give you an extra
Tempo and now you go root to G6 Rook G7
Rook G6 and now we get the same position
but the king is on C5 still the best
move is Rook to B7 but this does not
save black because once again we have a
race and a Tempo is crucial right he did
not see this transition he played the
move Rook to G6
King C4 Rook to B7 and right now the
computer just says that the position is
equal wow
yep yeah but it's equal but
equal but for us it's incredibly
difficult so difficult yeah I mean I I
feel like uh both players are on a very
narrow path and must play with some
accuracy Hikaru versus Sam sevion uh
that was uh this crazy triple Pawn
double pawn two sets of double pawns and
let me just kind of catch up with the
players here and he played the move a2a4
um did Hikaru
A4 well A5 is is coming and uh that
looks like very unpleasant
okay so I I'm forced to play C5 yeah
you'll go I assume please switch to Rook
C8 phones yes
and uh C8 that was my my dad Rook C8 and
because you played the move A4
I now have this one
five
acts played this one I'm not so sure
about because after Rook takes C5 rooked
now Rook C
6 maximize The Rook
okay and now
what what do I do I guess I would like I
would like trades I I think that's can
you park The Rook on B5 exactly I mean
after the move G4 I was in I was
thinking that you would protect this
Pawn but okay now I should be able to
suggest that I've got enough activity
after I force you to play Rook F2 that I
should draw but boy uh
Sam has to navigate some very very
tricky Waters he has played the move C5
and the Fabi versus Ray Robson also oh
sorry does he have only one minute and
55 seconds left on his clock yeah he
does is that accurate yeah or is it
seven minutes no no I've got 155. 55
against 14 minutes
well that's not great
and actually that's why he gets paid big
bucks as a coach guys this isn't great
this is not good for us keep it simple
A5 on the board what says the engine
about uh yeah Andrew says that white is
just dominant at this point it's
dominant three
completely winning three yes
wow
wow okay because after this move Rook C6
I do see
and now the white king can actually step
forward so F5 as well
yes that would be uh wonderful it just
reminds me of that game I don't know if
you guys play and I don't remember the
name where you just have this little
human behind blocks of stone and you
have to move the blocks of stone to get
the human out right
it looks exactly the same this end game
you have to go Rook to B3 Rook to B8
Rook to B6 you have to find the right
configuration and then at the right
moment play the move B3 and try to get
all the pieces into the game it's still
not easy and far from trivial this one
uh somehow I really think that Black's
Rook getting chased off the B file was a
very very big deal and now that I see
this passive Rook uh by black this Rook
sitting on C6 I do feel that uh Hikaru
is going to play Rook B8 from B6 kind of
like what you described is you get the
human into a better position and The
Rook on B6 is so let's see how that end
game is because this is also something
that Sam was talking about and he was
going towards these four versus three on
the same side type of end game so let's
go Rook to B8 okay black has to find a
move
to waste a Tempo probably came to H7
okay kick me H7 okay and I'll work the
B6 right all right take take Rook D6 and
we exchange a lot of Pawns how is that
position well this is the what you are
about to say Jovi I think was you get
your king F5 because yeah but I mean you
don't need to rush with this trade
either I mean you can wait so you can go
King F5 I I love these uh yeah like uh
patient moves if you will these low
moves of king of five and then once the
king king G7 you can wait once again you
know no need to rush can't Rook to be
something something about g42 because
Rook D3 I can always meet with F4 or
Rook C3 so but you want to be careful I
know I walked into a Checkmate uh
but after King Jesus sorry Jeffy yeah I
just wanted to wait seven one more time
please and just ask black what you gonna
do when I come for you yeah
it's a very good question in this case I
I I'm waiting okay and now we can
initiate this Rook b six and you've got
your kids
Superior square right yes so if this
case
you can go B7 I think yeah B7 to force
the Rook to take on B7 with the rook and
that loses the pawn on F6 yes
I like that
but now I can start with King G7
I don't have to take on B7 first
well you're the one who is
f6.
he says no you can't take that
I fell for uh
by the way we're gonna just take a quick
break as the as we've got uh Gary teed
up on the other side and we'll be right
back
nicely done
[Music]
founded in 1839 the University of
Missouri is steeped in Tradition the
recently founded Mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the University of
Missouri and the St Louis chess club
Collegiate Jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of Excellence
Mizzou has always strived for the best
Mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
Discovery and excellence
foreign
[Music]
family Welcome to our show
you guys gonna see this
that's our show now go start yours
[Music]
foreign
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85 000
students in both in school and after
school programs we created the select
chess training program in the junior
select chess training program in order
to elevate the skill level in students
across the St Louis area these students
receive professional training from Grand
Master varusian okobian other programs
include chess cops a partnership with
the St Louis Police Department looking
to improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019 the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 2 150 000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011. students
of chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chest
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to all the action of day
one in the American Cup and so far we've
had two games finished and also we have
in store for you something very special
because Gary Kasparov will join us on
the line
and get ready for some interesting
conversations absolutely Gary's always a
good interview welcome back Gary kasparo
but we do have uh round one of the
American Cup underway and I have to say
that Hikaru is just playing an
absolutely gorgeous a gem of an end game
uh he played the move King E3 and after
King G7 King E2 and he just
he just did everything right uh the last
few moves he's not he's we played Rook
takes D4 I was about to say I was it in
in my view it was just sort of like he
is he was just almost poetry like
playing the move Rook C2 and I just
thought uh he's going to just win this
pawn and cash in he played Rook takes D4
and probably
he's basically saying these two pass
pawned well pardon me this past Pawn is
going nowhere I'm just going to play
Rook to B6 play my Pawn to A6 I'm going
to win the game but is it so simple I
think it's simple unless unless because
I was thinking okay the Deep Pawn has no
future so Black's only chance is to kind
of trade off all those pawns so I'm
thinking the C Pawn is the way forward
so after playing C3 one takes and then
you know rocks belong behind past Pawn
so after Pawn takes Pawn Rook C6 you
know what I'm thinking black should do
the same thing as well beiruted two and
then move to The Rook with the Rook but
the problem is you're playing
unfortunately a king down
[Laughter]
and now if black could just like wait he
would be just fine right but
unfortunately there's no waiting move
any any move with the King drops the
point that's beautiful yeah that that is
beautiful and well calculated by Hikaru
I have to say wow
um really really impressive stuff and by
the way this is the way you have to beat
Sam sevion uh he's really a tough player
I mean no question about it and uh in
this particular game I just think that
uh Hikaru has just played outstanding
and uh he he's going to be uh he's going
to be very happy with this Victory today
it looks so yeah after all just take a
look at some stats you know rating of
26.87 I think he's also been hovering
around the 2700 for some time and this
will be 2017 American Continental chess
champion as well didn't he tie for first
as well in the U.S Championship he
didn't he lost in the tie breaks I I
think that probably is more important
than American Continental Champion well
I don't know because it's one thing to
say hey I'm the U.S Champion it's
another thing to say I'm the champion of
the whole
continents I think doesn't that sound
better I mean but okay I agree with you
I read that time for first of the U.S
Champion is pretty good and uh Hikaru
looked very confident there as we saw
him writing down his move uh going to
the game of Lanier I think we should
stay with this one just because I feel
they're going to see a resignation very
soon right C3 by the way on the board
take on C3 and Hikaru getting ready to
mobilize his King yes move it to
blockade the seaport and unfortunately
our table on the left our border left
doesn't updates so maybe we can see the
actual bird's eye view of the players
right now
really it's not updating oh man that's
that's terrible
and by the way I will interrupt
ourselves to welcome uh
former world champion Gary Kasparov to
our show Gary good of you to join yep
yes great day thank you
how how are you
uh couldn't be better couldn't be better
yes praying for Saint Patrick for
creating a miracle and for putting
receiving a warrant from international
criminal court of The Hague
probably you missed it yes absolutely
have
wow yeah so that's why I'm smiling okay
uh Gary you're going to be 60 years
young this year how are you feeling
about that I should ask you yes
I'm getting younger I don't know about
you so am I so yeah
uh Gary we need good news good news to
keep us in shape and um today is a good
day yeah and talking about good days I
mean it's the start of the American Cup
where we have this really new format of
double elimination I mean what are your
thoughts on this
look it's a never-ending debate about
the four months but uh clearly reaching
a point where um you know Knockouts
eliminations they definitely have you
know strong public support so I think
people somehow are not are no longer
Keen to see Yasser you know the tourism
of our use
or or our mature years you know one who
played the days and weeks everybody
wants to see the resolution yeah as
quickly as possible speaking of uh
seeing days and weeks and a little bit
old school we've got a world
championship match coming up next month
your thoughts uh Gary about this world
championship match are you looking
forward to it let's start with the
obvious uh look
um I can how hardly call the world
championship match so for me the world
championship match should include the
strongest planet and this match doesn't
I'm not here to comment on magnum's
decision but it's
um it's kind of amputated event so um
and as you know I had my own history
with fetus so that's why I'm I'm not
going to change my view about be the
championship so it's a Pity Magnus is
not there and naturally the match
between uh an apple and ding you know
it's a it's a great show anyway but it's
not a world championship match you know
in my house by the way sorry to
interrupt you uh Gary we do have a
victory by Hikaru I don't know if you
saw this game but it was a very
impressive rook and pawn end game
display by uh actually I thought I saw I
saw the game you know just on on on
another app so I just said and it seemed
to me that Hikaru just you know
gradually increased his advantage and
it's
King G7 and what's happened then
H5 King G7 at uh probably you're talking
about a moment
uh way back on move 31 I don't know if
that is right that's like 20 moves ago a
lot of things have happened but Hikaru
didn't need to manage uh to swing it
into his favor
it was this very nice
A4 A5 and then he got in G4
yeah and it was all very well it was so
many it was so many weaknesses you know
I was two Rooks on board so I I thought
it just it was a matter of time yeah uh
continue with your thoughts about the
world championship you say it's an
amputated World Championship it feels
wrong that Magnus isn't there but the
reality is that Magnus didn't want to
play the match I mean he made it very
clear he's uh he wanted something
different yeah no look you know again
it's it's uh it's it doesn't diminish
you know the achievements of Nepal and
Dink who qualified fair and square to
play this match but I think the
difference with the let's say 1975 when
Corporal became world champion and
Fisher walked away uh is quite obvious
Fisher
stop has stopped playing chess right
Magnus has not right and uh and that's
why it's very odd situation especially
for grantchester because we will have
quote-unquote world champion in in a
month's time and the strongest player on
the planet at the same time in the same
tournament I mean by the way maybe
that's that's what we need now kind of
sensation and uh more excitement
um and uh picking my favorite among
these two I don't know I think it's just
it's the uh both are very good players
and um
it's a couple of years ago I would say
ding but now after pandemics I think
nepo had better a performance uh and
also he had an experience of playing the
world championship match he lost the map
but he had some experience and that's
that's probably gives him a slight Edge
um though I think Dingus is probably
more stable than Nepal but yeah I I
think it's a very very close call
Gary uh speaking of the grandchester we
will also see The Return of one uh Ali
Reza firusha the reigning defending
champion of the grand Chester he's been
dipping his toes into the fashion world
as well what do you feel about that and
do you feel this is going to impact his
game
I I don't know actually it's the uh you
caught me by surprise
I uh I I I see nothing wrong with with
uh Ali with uh sarugia uh making you
know a quick Buck on the side I think
Magnus also did something something of
of of that type but he's actually taking
classes in in fashion glasses ah so
that's something okay I uh classic wow
that's I I mean
glasses and fashion yes
you see what you see what it takes to be
world champions these days uh Gary it's
a different it's different than when you
were a world champion I don't know if
you took fashion classes yourself
we were busy with other things uh look
uh I can I
I I can appreciate you know any any
other activities outside of of chess
boards uh uh uh it's it's it's it's
their choice to make but I I would be
I'll be watching them playing at the
chess board and uh and I think it's this
year grunches too has probably the
strongest field ever uh or one of the
strongest maybe the strongest because we
will have all the top players uh
competing in different tournaments I
mean Magnus is not a part of the whole
cycle but he will be featured in two
events and um I uh I think that's
that'll be a lot of excitement
especially because they there will be a
separation of the official quote-unquote
title and and the uh um uh unofficial
title the strongest player
uh if I can ask you uh the obvious
question uh what are you doing with your
time these days
uh it's most of my time now is is is uh
addressed Eastward of New York and uh
yeah and that's why you know I I I I was
very busy today and actually it's still
you know a couple more interviews
because of this uh big announcement so
which again even even I have to admit it
caught caught me by surprise uh just uh
didn't expect uh Courtney Hague to to
have guts to to uh declare Putin more or
less declaring into a war criminal he is
but uh the interesting thing is that you
know he he was um the warrant was issued
for for something that wouldn't even
considered to be a crime for kidnapping
Ukrainian kids uh and the reason they
did it because he he bragged about it on
television
it's like you know having Al Capone you
know uh charged with tax tax evasion
having having so many murders but tax
evasion something they could prove and
amazingly the man just whether it's
endless list of crimes and skills the
rivers of blood he actually got caught
because he bragged on television about
uh Russians kidnapping hundreds of
thousands of Ukrainian kids and shifting
them to Russia
wow okay well definitely going to have
to uh read that uh Christian Jovi uh any
questions for uh Gary do we have
anything from the Twitter sphere uh and
we warned our viewers that you were
coming on so I was expecting perhaps you
have one I I do have one final one later
on but Jovi I'll give you the uh yeah no
I mean the main thing that I was kind of
curious about because we kind of moved
on to the subject of Chess and studying
in the spare time I mean what kind of
subjects or areas do you think go hand
in hand with chess
wow
I think a lot because chess definitely
offers uh you a chance to improve many
of your qualities that could help you in
doing whatever you know from investing
to playing poker so uh
um these days you know people always you
know talk to me uh about my experience
with computers because the human machine
collaboration competition uh has become
a hot topic again
with child GPT and and all renewed fears
about machines intervention in our lives
and the and threats to to our very
existence so people recall uh
um our experience of fighting the
machines and uh definitely you know I I
I
um I I qualify uh since I I probably was
the first year knowledge worker who had
his job threatened by computer
and to finish it on a chess note Gary I
want to ask you about the youngest
participant in this event at least Lee
It Feels by her recent performances that
we have a future Grandmaster on our
hands did you get a chance to see her
games maybe uh assist her in any way and
what is your take on her
oh she is the member of our program so
of kisparov Chess Foundation program uh
uh the problem we started uh back in
I think it's not if I'm not mistaken we
already had 20 grand Masters because the
the original
um uh um uh group the first generation
included Sam Shanklin and then ordnisky
and then we moved on so probably every
American Grandmaster I think except
Neiman yeah so just somehow he has just
got involved with with our activities uh
and preparation and uh uh she now is is
a part of the of of our program so this
is it's it's it's a latest edition of
Casper of jazz Foundation which
celebrated uh last November our 20th
anniversary so um yeah it's not a
surprise so we knew from the moment we
saw her that we had another Grandmaster
in our hands right uh just to interrupt
you Gary we do have some updates uh
begum has won her game against
um touch nem server and we expect that
Alice Lee is about to win in uh by the
way Gary I've got a I I've got to uh
provoke a thought if you will there was
a game earlier that Arena crushes won
against tatev and I reminded of your
game against deep Jr uh back in the day
where deep Junior you played a match
with deep Junior and deep Jr shocked
everybody with Bishop takes H2 check
okay game five for the match yeah so
this is yes yeah and there was a game
that will our producers will bring it up
on the board that forcibly reminded me
of your game with deep Junior and I
remember being so shocked that the
computer gave up a piece your reaction
yeah yeah this is that's that's that's
that's quite quite a shock because it
was not so I saw Bishop xh2 but I saw it
was not winning and you know machine you
know had to play uh with you know just
was com I mean strong compensation I
either way it's it's is since you
mentioned the game have you ever checked
uh uh this position with with our modern
chat engines they would would they go
with with this line Bishop takes H2 or
yeah we disregard it as two two uh
provocative I I checked it years ago
with something like maybe deep Fritz 12.
and uh it like Bishop H2 uh but it felt
it was even it was a draw I don't know
what the modern most sophisticated
engines would think of the move yeah
it's a draw because that's what's
happening in our games yeah it's uh it
was you know uh quick landed in a draw
uh but it is because I I didn't take my
chance of playing you know more
complicated position so um and again
also I I was quite shocked after my
blood in game three because unlike
unlike the match with with the blue I
totally dominated the first two games
yeah and even game three I a very good
position not winning but just was very
close and then terrible blunder you know
just that turned this game you know just
lost game in one in one move uh
um uh had us had a had a scarf on my
memory so that's why I didn't I didn't
have energy to to push Hardy against
deep Jr so I was quite happy with us
ending up uh um three three having a tie
exactly Gary uh we've got uh guests
coming in studio we want to thank you
for taking time out of your busy
schedule most appreciated you look great
oh awesome yes
you know I think this everything is just
you know it's laying ahead okay yes
thank you for joining us thank you and
bye-bye and we do have by the way the
women are turning in an amazing
performance three out of three uh the
three games of all been victories for
white they have yeah and uh
coincidentally everyone playing with the
white piece is actually the higher rated
as well as the arena
the color white and the drawing of lots
yesterday and they are very impressive
start I have to say from the players
with the white pieces I mean I I love
the way Alice played it and I also liked
the control of that
game showed in her game against uh
Katarina yeah she got this kind of
dominating kind of uh spatial advantage
and it was this night on E8 a very very
passive night versus a night on D5 as
I'm just playing through the game right
now and it was just a really a great
performance by uh begum the move G5
coach you're you're happy with your your
your player today she well you said I'm
getting coach of the day
I'll take it
we're waiting for tomorrow
but uh very impressive game very very
impressive and it does mean that
everyone who lost today is in a must-win
situation tomorrow they have to win with
a with the white pieces their backs are
against the wall if they lose if they
draw draw the game then they will fall
down to their Elimination Brackets where
their one chance has been taken away and
they're fighting for survival in Rapid
chess and strangely enough we had this
other this this rook and partying game
as well uh that kind of
well after I'm sorry the move F5 that
just kind of made it a little bit too
easy for Alice she was able to collect
all of black spawns and went on to win
so an easy game there Anna zatonski
still struggling she's a pawn down
against Naji
closer to a draw than anything and uh
Lanier
I think that's a big one that we still
have right now still uh quite unclear
that end game
looks like they're playing but it is
going to be a draw very soon in that
right
and uh Lavon uh
flexing like it does he loves doing that
it's it's like a stretch Flex type of
thing all right right look at it
but I in this moment after I see this
move Rook F6 uh by Lanier I think that
the draw is very very close uh because
you pick up the pawn on H6 is there's
absolutely no no problems for for black
anymore the double left pawns aren't
going anywhere and if anything I start
to think well maybe I'm going to be
better as white in the meanwhile we have
a guest with Christian in studio uh we
do have Hikaru Nakamura who is making
his uh debut here at the American Cup
Hikaru welcome to the studio first round
first win how do you feel right now yeah
it's pretty good I mean I I I'm on I was
on a one-game losing streak having not
played classical chess in something like
nine months um so it's quite nice to get
a win I mean I think the game is very
interesting uh I noticed it was kind of
similar to lavon's game that they're
double triple pawns everywhere on the
board
um which was you know kind of
interesting but I I don't think it was
ever really
um tricky per se for me a lot of my
decisions were pretty straightforward
unfortunately for Sam without a second
time control in particular it was very
very difficult and he just didn't find
the right continuations I mean I think
probably he started going wrong pretty
early on I mean I think I think okay
this is all completely fine of course uh
and yeah I mean takes takes how did you
assess this position yeah I mean I
thought I was better actually okay
castles is the right I didn't play
castles because I was worried about uh
like I thought he could go like Queen E8
and then some F6 and C5 and queen F7 and
I mean I guess wow it's not that much
better for white that's surprising I
thought it was better I just didn't know
how much better so yeah well I mean if I
was 3 500 I could play I could Castle I
mean I considered it but I just didn't
really see and I thought Rook D1 was the
other thematic move because black can't
go C5
um that being said I thought that after
Queen E8 for example castles
C5 Bishop C3 F6 I know it looks very
ugly for black but white doesn't really
have a whole lot going on
um I mean okay it wants to go B3 and
claim some big advantage in the long
term but at least for me looking at this
while it looks ugly for black I didn't
see a clear way to progress here at some
point I can try F4 and E5 to break in
the center but I I don't really think
it's that easy to do and I thought it
was better I didn't think it was a whole
lot
um I thought what Sam did also should
have been okay but yeah already here it
gets it's kind of tricky because you
feel like you're very close to a draw
but you can also be very far from a
drawn I think when he played um G takes
F6 this was really the start of his big
problems here takes takes and not taking
with the Rook basically what I concluded
is that here after Rook takes let's just
say I go Rook D3 for example king f8
um Rook C1 King E7 I don't know takes
takes Rook C3 King D7 here I mean white
is better of course but if black and
Goldberg beat him like just as just say
white plays like G3 here just Rook B8 B3
and then Rook b60 even I think black
should be okay here because you have the
active rook and The Rook on B6 is
passive temporarily but you can always
go Rook before later on so I thought
this was the best setup
um whereas in the game once you got once
you get these double pawns on F6 I mean
I think uh it's really really hard to
play because I never have to trade off
the pawn on C5 or D6 and then he has to
take the triple pawns on the C file and
from there I mean I suspect the computer
still will find some way to hold it but
it didn't seem practical in the game you
mentioned uh the absence of the second
time controller uh did that play into
your decision to enter these two result
end game no I mean I I haven't played
classical chess in a very long time so I
just want to do something simple
um and really I think that's the main
thing is you never really you never know
how you're going to react when you
haven't played for so long I mean
obviously when I played in Berlin after
after an even longer break I did quite
well but nonetheless I wasn't really
sure and I also felt that Sam he's a
much more tactical aggressive player
that's not to say that he can't play
positional shots but I feel like that's
his strength and so of getting him out
of that I thought gave me better chances
absolutely and when did you feel like
you were closing the show
um I felt around the time that he he got
stuck when he didn't play C5 so when he
played Rook B6 yeah right around here we
were discussing C5 here we felt that C5
was was the better move okay interesting
computer still thinks it's really bad
wow but you know it's also always hard
to judge because basically just as an
example say I go King G3 Rook B6 say
Rook takes C4 Rook B2 Rook C5 it doesn't
matter Rook A2 and just like I don't
know Rook A7 A5 like it you never really
know because this end game if Rook takes
A5 if basically Rook takes A5 later yeah
I just mean if we get this end game
where I have
have an extra Pawn
um this is this is a draw so you're
never really sure whether it's
completely winning or not
um but somewhere around here when he got
stuck with this Rook on B6 I eventually
was able to play A4 A5 it felt like it
had to be winning
and Sam was getting low on the clock as
well and yeah I I don't think I was
really ever thinking about like when it
was winning or not winning but I just
kept trying to play the best moves and
seemed to work out talk to us about the
format of this tournament how do you
feel that impacts your decision-making
process
um
well you mean having a loser packet or
yes the loser bracket as well as all the
time controls available yeah I don't
think it really changes much uh I mean
really the only thing I'm trying to do
is not lose games in classical chats so
I can keep my rating otherwise that's
all that I'm doing so I I'm not really
thinking that much about the format um
but of course I think it's great that
for example if you have one really bad
day and you lose a match you have a
chance to come back and redeem yourself
so I think from that standpoint it's
quite good guys any questions
wonderfully uh done I thought it was a
very instructive uh game Hikaru and uh
good luck tomorrow
thank you absolutely as we have uh
levada remaining and the game between
Fabi and Rey is going to be drawn I mean
uh Fabi has been a pawn down against Ray
for some time but there's just simply no
way that you're ever going to get this
Pawn past the purview of the bishop the
bishop is ready to sacrifice itself
it's all about that Levon game right now
yes I mean the Dominguez with 20 seconds
on the clock 44 right now what 20
seconds Levon with only one minute on
the clock this is going to get wild
wow 22nd 20 seconds because he gained 30
seconds but okay The Rook has moved up
to
we have Rook H4 as the last move and the
board on the left is definitely an old
position not the current position let me
just refresh yep we've got uh this is
the current position
on the analysis board apologies for that
is we just have Rook da check has been
played yep and then we can see it I do
feel that this is the type of position
and also bearing in mind the clock
situation where both sides will perhaps
be looking to simplify
and meanwhile we do have a guest with
Christian right now in the studio thank
you Jovi we are indeed with Google nova
after a big victory for her tell us a
bit about this game tell us a bit about
this matchup you know Katarina quite
well you've played her before how do you
feel about this matchup and today's game
I'm pretty comfortable with her because
I have been playing like for some reason
many games since
2021 so I'm comfortable and I believe
she's comfortable because we know each
other well
so and the game started like pretty
badly for her she just got a little bit
like bad structure and I had space more
space and it was easier for me to play
and after Bishop G4 here and after
Bishop E2 I was surprised that she took
on F3 I thought she's gonna take twice
and then she or she can take only two
yeah that's true only two would be
better I guess but she took on F3 and
then she played Bishop isaman so I
thought when she took on uh through at
least like instead of Bishop E7 C5 would
be better because if I attack on C6
right now you can take him yeah
go C5 I mean at least she has some like
compensation for the bishop right I felt
like Knight on D4 is
um like strong but after Bishop E7
we should be true I don't think now she
had to play that after I'm taking on C6
she cannot take with the pawn so she
needs to attack back she doesn't have
enough time for she has to interpose
this check Knight takes F3 the problem
is that this structure is just very bad
yeah it's very bad at some point I I
think I could play even C5 and sacrifice
the
like before maybe before yeah here even
like I was thinking of it opposite of
you see one okay like C5 C5 take and
just um just to play this game Rook C1
Knight A4 B3 but I wasn't sure because
Rook B8 Rook P4 and she would start
attack my E4 Pawn even though I had like
Knight C5 and she she's not on time to
take my E4 Pawn I wasn't sure it felt
like even after C5 I have a very
comfortable play
one thing that I noticed is that she was
spending a lot of time and you were
maintaining your lid on the clock uh did
you feel that was part of your strategy
as well no it's just easier for me to
play this position I know my like moves
right and for her she needs to come up
with something for example G6 all these
like ideas with F5 maybe at some point
she had to push F5 instead of 47 it felt
like and then uh at this point at five
yeah
I was going to play F3 like
yeah and I was thinking of G4 at some
point that I could play for you okay
yeah not to give F5 at all but I was
like I'm Waking my king I I already have
a weakness remember what your coach told
you don't weaken your king anymore all
right I was like my coach is gonna
attack me so let's stay on G2 okay very
good you did the right thing
um and when did you feel like you're
pretty much wrapping up the game taking
over actually when I found this idea
Rook H1 and slowly G3 F4 F5 everything
is coming and I was very annoyed that I
played uh King D3 because uh initially
my initial idea was to play King F3 and
then I was like wait a sec let let's put
the king there so after Knight C7 Knight
E six I won't have Knight G5 or Knight
D4 checks right at all but like it was
too General I could I could just play
King F3 King it Knight E3 Knight F5 and
I could take on this six yeah unlike
that position with the King on day three
when you take on D6 you have some pins
that's why I was a little bit uh annoyed
and I felt like uh her King was moving
back and I felt it's a little bit harder
but she just didn't have time and she
blundered G5 and G6 after and time
indeed was off the essence she finished
with only two minutes on the clock a big
victory for you to start off uh your
campaign here at the American Cup uh
what are your aspirations let's say for
for this event
goal taking a lot of my time just
this year I'm doing my internship too so
I haven't been playing that much I feel
I feel like I haven't been playing for
like a year or two I was so away from
from Chelsea in general from Chess World
so it's good to be back and play some
chess congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
as well very nice game we do have a
Lavon and a linear Lanier is in a
situation where basically he's on the
increment and
yeah yeah exactly actually uh it's hard
for me to tell because one minute 15
seconds yeah
um very technical position an extra Pawn
but I don't
feel like I I just don't see how as
white is going to make progress in this
position whenever you play King G4 I'm
gonna I'm not going to let you give me a
check exactly and drive me back I'll
give you a check and then I'll maintain
my connection with the pawn on B2 like
so I'm thinking that as white uh
you're eventually going to have to take
this guy and you go into a table based
position and I think uh most of these
positions there's a simply draw I could
just see that you know yeah
every single thing and meanwhile we do
have another guest in the studio we are
indeed with Alice Lee after a tremendous
performance in game one Alice every time
I see you it feels like you're more and
more confident your game gains more
confidence do you feel that way as well
and I've seen you play in the Pro chess
league as well you've been carrying the
Saint Louis Arch Bishops how do you feel
about that and this tournament yeah I
think like the past few tournaments
including like the protest League I had
like a lot of opportunity to play
against really strong players
um this tournament is no exception so I
feel as though like I can
um I can realistically speaking have
chances against anybody uh and in this
opening uh this game I guess
um I think it was like a pretty smooth
game I got a good position of the
opening and then I felt like I had like
a very pleasant end game to play and she
had like lower time so yeah I think this
game definitely went well but I still
have another game tomorrow how did you
come up with this idea of starting off
with this aggressive F3 against the
names though
um so
I sort of thought like I want to have
like a win
um at least here I have better chances
with the white pieces
and uh and it's the first game so you
want to put pressure on her yeah so
um this move is like something that I've
never played before it's sort of like
gets out of her preparation and
um yeah I like I overall just thought
that like this was a good line to play
especially to play for a win
um so she probably wouldn't be reviewing
this before the game and uh I would be
able to get a position where I just
reviewed it so it's more comfortable for
me to like play I probably will have
more time out of the opening
um and yeah I think that strategy worked
for this game
and did you feel that you're achieving
your goals based on her time Spencer in
the position it didn't feel like she's
very comfortable uh with this position
yeah
um so actually I didn't know this line
too well I knew up to like uh move 12
and then I didn't know what to play
after Rook two years yeah so
I think uh this is like a pleasant
position
um and like obviously I had like a a bit
more time than her
uh 10 minutes more and I think in this
position uh I thought like this would be
pretty Pleasant I didn't know exactly
but I thought like I probably will be
able to like trade into an end game and
I'll probably play like E4 and my Bishop
on uh the dark sir Bishop is really good
um so I thought I had pretty good
winning chances here and that's exactly
what happened you entered this Superior
end game
just slightly but definitely you have
some pressure and you're playing for two
results
how did you assess it and what were your
strategic AIMS in this end game what
were you playing for uh so here I guess
I have like 30 minutes yes uh 11. so
um I saw like uh this position I didn't
I didn't know whether it was like a win
or a draw uh I thought like but I saw
that the work ending would definitely be
like really unpleasant for her to play
especially with much lower time and I
felt like I had extremely good practical
mini chances so I'm not sure if this was
like I had any
um other better moves here but I thought
objectively this was uh practically
speaking this is like
um this should be like very hard for her
to play and he made that transition and
Yasser was in fact very happy with this
transition he was giving you more than
75 chances at this point to win this
game did you feel the same yeah I
thought like
and if I'm able to sort of defend
consolidate the king side still remain
upon up then I can probably like
activate my kin more toward the center
um possibly create like G3 F4 passed
upon
um which I think I sort of uh did in the
game and then like maybe bring my king
in more
um and yeah I think the a Pawn on the
side is to my advantage even though my
work is stuck defending it because yeah
here eventually I was able to win it
after her work got sidetracked and after
this I think I was just winning very
nice Alice congratulations on an
explosive start in this tournament guys
any questions absolutely first of all
our congratulations to you uh Alice for
a wonderful start to your campaign this
year last year you were a finalist
um but you're coming into this
tournament with one year's experience
and it seems to ourselves that this one
year has been very very good to you your
your your career is you you've been
doing great why
um I think I spent like a lot of time on
chess especially like
um I've been trying to like Branch out
in my play style uh like go for these
more attacking openings
um and I think uh the past year has been
pretty good uh I think mostly I just
gained a lot more experience especially
from like playing in these tournaments I
played in this last year and I think
that gave me like
um a lot of like experience playing
against drum players and I've been uh
playing and strong tournaments like
almost every month so I think overall my
uh form is pretty good I just like
played in a tournament before this
um and yeah so I think like overall uh
the past year I definitely gained more
experience and that has definitely
helped me improve yeah and uh once again
congratulations on on winning your first
game and you mentioned that you were
playing a lot of Chess and I'm sure all
parents out there would be really dying
to know
um how do you combine chess with the
schoolwork
um so I'm actually a part-time student
I'm in eighth grade so uh there isn't
too much schoolwork
um
I have like one math class at the
University which is taking like a lot of
time but other than that I think uh
since I'm still in middle school next
year will probably be like more uh like
tough for me to manage with schoolwork
but I'll still keep trying to like play
chess I can probably like I usually talk
to my teachers before I go to a
tournament so they can give me there
would be four time and I try to do it uh
before or sometimes
um like during or after tournaments and
yeah I think overall like the balance
for schoolwork and chess hasn't been too
difficult for me although I have missed
like a lot of school you said the word
universe
exactly Alice you alerted us what did
you mean by that University what type of
University
um there's a math program at the U of M
called MTM so it's like
um pretty Advanced and
um it like teaches people from like six
to 12th grade
um high school and college math So
currently I'm in my first year of cow
Juan and
um
it's like
um it's been a bit difficult to keep up
but I think overall since my grades are
okay
um I usually try to they only have like
one class a week so I only have to like
uh if I have like a tournament I can
probably like do stuff beforehand
um but yeah overall that's like the only
difficult class for me
um and the rest is okay
well Alice congratulations go to some
more calculon homework I stopped at
college algebra guys I mean I stopped at
college algebra you probably passed that
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you wow
[Laughter]
ladies isn't she 13 years old I'm
playing impressive chess right also at
University
[Laughter]
the future is really bright super right
let me get on my sunglasses levonne uh
is still upon up he's trying his best
two games remaining as uh he is on the
sunny side of torture and then we have
Anna versus Naji
in this case really it's just a pawn but
it's kind of like the Ray Robson Pawn
it's not going anywhere at all and and I
do expect that it's much easier for
white to make a draw than for black even
to create any any threats nonetheless
you're upon it you gotta go well you are
a pawn up but I mean it's really not
much of a phone because I feel that in
these type of situations if the porn had
been in the center then there's a lot
more angles to play with here I mean
it's just very simple you mean there's
no way the king is in front of the pond
so it makes it very very difficult to
push upon home and if you were to trade
off Bishops like Anna's constantly
trying to get naughty to do she has then
it is just a straightforward draw I mean
there's no way that white can go wrong
exactly
exactly now on the other hand it seems
to me there's more tricks uh in the
position for Lanier I mean here there
are ways that white can trap his
opponent into well obviously a move for
example King F5 Rook check you're going
to have to go back to G6 yeah I think I
think you can go to F6 also oh can you
go to F6 yeah why not and I think he
actually did he did go to F6 you're
absolutely right
and unfortunately for you you don't have
Rook A5 but do you have to disturb the
harmony of the position because
you know
well King H4 is going to be met by
primary Rook H2 check right yeah sorry
my my bad King H4 Rook H2 check and
we're right back to where we are
currently it just seems like
Lanier probably has found the system to
make the draw right now
the setup is is complete so uh three
draws we expect in the open section one
win for Hikaru three wins for the ladies
and only one draw there's something
about that and all wins for white
um
yeah I think nauseatingly the closest
yeah but even then that's just right
just to pawn up wow Ray also I got yeah
portents of things to come why is it
that uh White dominated this round
it's just good openings it's good I mean
if we have to say the the victors all
played exceedingly well right I mean it
was really yeah it was one-way traffic
you know when you look up Arena how she
beat out of there
right and Hikaru like you say you know
absolutely dominate against Sam but we
have to remember that in both sections
the higher rated player did start with
the white pieces yeah
and our predictions
um I'm I'm chill okay
rocking it
and what about the ladies uh where did I
go with that one you went to Arena I
want it oh wow you both went to Arena
not bad not bad I think we're all doing
okay I mean tomorrow it's crunch time
well I mean coach of the day over there
I mean he's wearing the biggest smile
begum came in and she didn't say
anything about your prep which is like I
mean where's the love
thank you coach
none of that ice cold
wow I was expecting her to say you know
I got a big advantage of the opening
thanks to my coach Christine
no no no I played real really well here
and I played really well there and then
I really but if she loses yeah yeah it's
definitely my fault you know how he goes
I know how it goes
and by the way big shout out to the St
Louis chess club the the St Phil's for
providing such a fantastic presence take
a look at it and we have a total price
fund of two hundred thousand dollars and
first place Nets 50 000 not bad for like
ten ten days of work second place 35
000 and then when it comes to the
women's section in first place gets
twenty five thousand dollars second
eighteen thousand and a total price fund
of a hundred thousand
incredible stuff nice nice very very
impressive uh Lavon not making much
progress we do expect
a draw here a just try King E4 but after
Rook check uh we've seen this video yeah
you want to risk it and try to go to D4
and try to capture that pawn on A4 with
the king or is that allowing the the H
Point
uh
isn't there I mean I might risk it a bit
too much right I I think so well
actually what are you doing about age
four different casting King C3 you go H3
H3 this is not not good yeah yeah
this is not the
not what you signed up for there that H
Pawn could really
and he's done oh he's doing it King D3
you can always go back you can always go
back yeah
Rook have two attacking the pawn
again the players are playing on the
increments
wow but uh
say it so if you do go King C3 because I
somehow feel that that's that's the kind
of most critical task now you run and
now the white Rook is released for this
Camp prison and I couldn't well I'm
about to play Rook takes F4 and that
that protects this guy and this guy
makes the draw that much easier
just a second okay
now Rook B4 is really asking is it
asking for trouble may I try it try it
over let's go H4 H4 gift meet upon
okay and run again
um or let's keep going we'll run again
G7 King G7
I mean I was wondering whether you could
just the F Pawn is kind of dead I was
wondering whether you could go a five
instead of giving a check all right
let's uh look see but here I'm afraid
you'll take this guy oh dear yeah no no
that's not what we signed up for right
so we were we were trying check and you
went King G7
yeah either way I think I'm going to
take that pawn on B2 first you don't
have enough time to defend that true I
have to come back and he's played King
E3 after all I mean it was just it was a
faint yeah
the idea of King C3 King E3 we expect
Rook H2
or oxito or roxy2 Rook H2 I just like to
keep that
pathway for the H Pawn to transformation
yeah you don't like the rook in front of
the H Pawn
it's the hover yeah the hand check and
then the main guess is just under a
minute it does get an extra 30 second
increment yeah
and they're both at one minute and 20
seconds right now
I always thought the Hover was bad it
really reminds me of these Scholastics
tournaments where almost as soon as the
player moves the opponent put the hands
out and it kind of hovers over the floor
but your clueless as to what you're
gonna do but you know your hand is ready
so never thought I like the pros who
don't hover until they're certain and
then the hand comes out and bang it
makes the move so there you saw the
hover yes but sometimes you know you
have no option but you know you have one
of those horrible moments where you grab
the piece you've confidently put it on a
square and a lot of precise minute in
time you realize oh my goodness me that
is a blunder of the highest proportions
right so you move it back and you move
it maybe to this another square right
yes yes exactly yeah
my my game with Joseph Dorfman he had
played Queen on C2 as white to C4 and
he's just really really screwed it into
the board like and really realized it
was a balloon
that was bad that was bad it was pretty
funny uh check and King F3 Rook D2
um any trickies uh Christian I don't see
the trickies for Lavon I don't see them
either no anyways it's just too simple
the young game is too simple and you can
never give me the B2 Pawn because
immediately after I have The Rook B3
chat right and and that's the key
so I can't I I cannot play Rook H6
because oh he's played Rook B4
okay
so uh some tricks and that's okay I'm
going to go to C2 I'm going to allow you
to take on A4 right right
what else am I supposed to do and
immediately the table base comes and
it's just drawn right across and by
table base we kind of mean that the
position has been so simplified that the
computers have managed to work it out
right all the possibilities
I I remember this is ages ago with the
whole idea of the table base came about
and
the term they used I don't know if they
still use it was God mode you know the
table base was like God this is it this
is a hundred percent accurate and it's
like dank
yeah it's quite impressive when you
think about it yeah actually that's five
pieces six pieces table base seven
pieces
yeah
uh
uh was playing in a tournament uh
Computing humans versus computers and it
was Roberto SE Fuentes
he was playing this very complicated
Rook ending and I was watching watching
15 minutes Roberta played the move I I
wanted him to play in the
the
operator uh said I'm sorry a check made
in 47.
I said Roberto don't believe him
I don't believe this Checkmate in 47.
ah that was really bad uh we Lavon did
oops excuse me
um come on there it is
there it is that's the position and King
G3 on the board King G3 let's continue
staying on the second rank rule D2 I
would assume so as well
um reason no and we might even have had
this position previously on the board
right I remember rugby five King F6
and we were analyzing that position
right
uh as as far as coaching and working
with players
and do you advise your students that you
know you're a pawn up ex you know
exploit your every chance oh absolutely
yeah you don't just say all the way
until the end you have to put as much
pressure and as much continuous pressure
on your opponent until the last trick uh
in the position it's simple uh is as
simple as that and I do like the tagline
that Magnus like famous kind of grind
Masters like Magnus Carlson use they say
you're not here to make friends no
you're just there to play chess and if
you save points I mean that's a bonus if
you win drawn positions even better
great
[Laughter]
just on that note actually is a really
funny I
okay uh just on that note actually is a
really funny I I studied rook and Bishop
versus rook and in seven times in my
tournament career I mean I'm talking
classical chess I achieved that ending
and every time I achieved it whether I
was on the weaker side or the superior
side I always scored the maximum result
and I was very proud of myself until
Hikaru
scored a win with the Rook oh and he
beat Magnus
yes it was an Oslo yes correct at a
certain moment Magnus was playing with
the rook and Bishop and realized he
wasn't going to so now he was trying to
trade the rook and Hikaru was playing
for the white on the clock and achieved
the win on the clock and that was
remarkable yeah to see the grind mice
losing with an extra piece yeah that's
that's impressive but I mean the clock
is a part it's a part of the game yes it
is do you have to be practical indeed
that's why I'm in favor of like these
Armageddon chess yeah because I feel
like you know we we kind of when I
started playing chess you know the clock
was very much important I mean you know
you had to be quick physically you had
to always incorporate that aspect of the
game and another thing is you had to
hold your nerve and you had to bully
your opponent with the clock right and I
felt like with this increment you lost
that aggression and somehow are they you
know you got yourself into losing
positions and you almost had to resign
because you know this increment and it
just kind of killed the game and killed
the fun for me but now you know with
Armageddon chess I mean we see this
Savage nature of chats we see the
players like stumbling pieces flying
everywhere making illegal moves going
playing dodgy but I mean I love it it's
you know chess is a real street fight
there yeah uh it's funny because uh Gary
was on the show and there was a world
championship the fide world championship
of Rapid shares uh between uh Gary and
Afghani barriev
and it was the finals and it was held in
France and we were all Spellbound
and the position froze and the players
were going bang bang bang bang bang and
the screen froze and bang bang and
Gary one won the World Championship in
Rapid chess came down we were all like
what happened well the dgt board froze
because Gary made an illegal move he put
his king in check neither player
realized that his King's in check the
game continued and he won and the and
the dgt board would not allow an illegal
move
[Laughter]
what's going on in uh Lavon and Lanier
Christian nothing nothing it's the same
position that we left it with and Rook
to B4 he Levon tried Rook to be able to
have a mixed fat check from a behind now
he's back to lateral checks but nothing
has changed and you can actually see
Dominguez is looking hey look you're
checking his scores do we have a
threefold repetition at any point and
finally Levon decides to take the pawn
on A4 but this is not going to change
the simple one is King to F6 King to G6
also works it's just as fine I think the
one thing you do not do is play King E4
King e no absolutely is the one that's
the landmine Square that's where you
blow yourself up after rookie five check
that's an important point the King has
to remain behind right the enemy
opponent and incidentally there were
only two losing moves it was moving the
king to that square or intercepting the
check
[Laughter]
this is of course what I meant was that
King E4 that was the landmine that was
the booby trap and after Rook check King
here you end up in a situation where the
the the king is actually funnily enough
cut off
along the fifth rank so that I could
just play
King G5 and F5 and easily make a win in
that case so don't play and he didn't of
course he played King F6 and king of
three on the board
let me just update my board apologies
yes yeah three king of three and uh yeah
I mean Lanier has found the formula and
every time the white king is going to
approach the black king Rook is going to
come and give a check
how do we do it right now what's the
move Rook B3 I go King V4 right that's
right yeah then why not wait along the
second row so you go wrong to C2 yeah
exactly come past me um
why don't I just go Rook A2 yeah
I mean just to uh make sure that anytime
you do go Rook takes H5 I'm not even
going to let you play King E4 and Rook
H4 H6 check I know it's a draw but I'll
take on A3 with a check yeah he seems to
be going for or to B3 check look to B3
check that's one move that I didn't want
to do is yeah before and now you
probably want to run with the H Pawn
Yeah simple just okay but somehow it
feels like allowing my king to right be
taken back on the seventh rank it just
doesn't feel that comfortable
I'm sure yeah in fact I do have a table
base come out and it does say it's drawn
but it is strange to allow Rook check
and to allow the white king so I think
what he wants is whenever you go Rook A6
I go King G7 and now I'm starting to
have my own threats connected to the
fact that you cannot touch the H5 with
your Rook so maybe my H Pawn is going to
become quite dangerous
okay this is basically an invitation to
sign the score sheets right now right
okay it's five
Rook takes
I assume check
okay yeah there we go he's asking for
the arbit or whether they can make a
draw
they have to find the repetition which
is not going to be difficult
[Laughter]
yep and uh
we are going to see
King steps backwards and we're probably
going to see Rook takes Pawn
yeah no oh okay they found the
repetition
they spare absolutely no moves
I don't want to take your Pawn let's
just make the draw
and that concludes our open section
yes it does three draws in the open
section and one win a very impressive
win by Hikaru with three victories for
the ladies yeah and one game remaining
but we do think that would be a draw and
Naja is still at work she's trying she's
trying
um I I always very impressed because
they are actually on move 97. wow okay
and do you see a result there
congratulations to the linear by the way
I mean
he saved a difficult position absolutely
I mean the tip of your head I mean I've
seen Lavon out Fox the most crafty
players including Hikaru
I think it was in the candidates or
maybe a World Cup that he defeated icaro
in a drawn uh Rook ending but he's
outplayed the best okay with one game
remaining and that is as you were saying
97 move 97. wow they have to take it
right and I have to commend the chess
club what a beautiful plane call Imagine
playing with all these posters and
photographs of Bobby Fisher Gary Castro
Rose world champions behind you it's
such a beautiful playing hole Yeah
and so much space right yeah in between
in between boards Bishop to G1 and
I remember in my tournaments they never
allowed the wooden floors so they would
always have a kind of uh let's say a
East Middle Eastern carpet because
everybody was almost we didn't wear
rubber soled shoes we wore these hard
heel so yeah yeah all the time you heard
these horrible uh you know sounds of
people walking by so the carpet was
necessary if you look at these old
photos of the world championships and
these Soviet columns or something like
that a massive stage that also is kind
of carpet underneath yes
it definitely does involve a lot of
preparation in providing the best
tournament hall for the players because
it's not just you know the Acoustics as
you mentioned you also have to think
about the light you also have to think
about the ventilation and as a you both
have pointed out out you know you need
to give the players good Elbow Room
right there's nothing worse than playing
in a big tournament and you're like that
we opened the world opens I have this
one so yeah I went okay so I was a
little bit late to my game as usual and
I just got down I was paying you when
Jun in the Isle of Man yes the grand
Swiss and okay I've played some moves
and I felt like the person next to me
was taking up too much space and so I
was I was kind of almost tempted to like
nudge him out of the way I turned over
and looked and it was none other than
Vladimir cram next time
[Music]
don't go there you'll be
he's a big boy
six foot three it's about 250. and I
found
yeah exactly
and aha wow okay that man just secured
the draw Rook to D2 by by on move 100
give me a big I've only played it once
snooker but I'm a very very big snooker
fan I watched the world championships
and it's sort of like great whenever
they make a century in snooker I mean
the crowd stands up very nice Applause
you know I said you do that in chess
you get some complaints you get a
commentators please you know don't
invite these people back
well I think most of the time it's the
Arbiters that complain about these
hundred movers because they're like it
was dinner time
Bishop takes G3 and that secures the
draw as
uh well Naji is the only player to make
a draw with the black pieces in the
women's section uh Bring It On
well let's look at the results
definitely and uh first of all let's
check out the open section and we saw
the thoughts only one decisive result
with Hikaru Nakamura defeating Sam
sebion with the white pieces that leaves
Sam in a must-win situation yet tomorrow
exactly
and scrolling down we also have a draw
between Lavon aronian and Pennsylvania
Dominguez hard Fort was a crazy game at
points good defense by Lanier and
talking about gooder fans we also saw
Sam Shanklin just completely neutralized
Wesley so with the black pieces
beautiful movement I take C3 came just
in the nicotine and our fourth and Final
yeah it was a crazy game at points but
uh everything fizzled out to a draw
between a Fabiana caruana and Marie
Robson so everything to play for for
these three months Ray Ray will be proud
of his game today uh he actually had an
easy time of it Christian absolutely uh
he made a draw but he made a draw from a
dominant position starting with the
opening phase well he was definitely
phased out a little bit by this H4 move
by Fabiano and Fabiano was strolling
around the playing Hall you know showing
dominance and confidence nevertheless
Ray Robson he showed that he is in Peak
condition right now he is probably at
his best in his career right now over
2700 and he can definitely defend this
type of early opening surprises against
the best in the world and this is
exactly what he did today and maybe he
even had an advantage at some point in
this one mightily impressed with
yeah and for me I just bringing up the
position uh where where H4 followed by
the dynamic Queen H5
uh untool
never never understand what that was
about we have the benefit of hindsight
we can actually say it was a bad mood
but at the time we were like wow wow wow
age four age but we we haven't done
Justice of the event what about the
ladies of course and it was
Galore
it is
I have Arena Crush playing a fantastic
game against tatev Abraham and tatev
will be in a must win situation with the
white pieces tomorrow and begin tour
here in John over had again amazing game
against Katarina nemcover in full
control and she also leads one nil
and moving down Anna satonski and Naji
paikitsu they had a very long game a
hundred moves and it was a well-fought
draw there and finally finally we do
have the 13 year old Alice Lee
Victorious against a two Circle
percussion and she also leads warnell
and leaves a Tusa in a must-win
situation tomorrow so tomorrow we're
gonna have to see some blood on the
board for some players for sure and
final thoughts uh bring the show home uh
for us Christian I mean it was a great
start to the 2023 American Cup we had a
lot of Fighting Chess in the open
section we see Hikaru is definitely
hungry for some positive results and in
the late section I mean there's so much
combative just and I have to say Alice
Lee is just impressing me with each and
every game I think we have a future
Grand Master on our hands but tomorrow
some players will be with their backs
against the wall and we're going to see
if they manage to fight through that so
well check out check us out tomorrow
we'll do it all tomorrow Jovi it was
wonderful it's great to have you back in
studio thank you so much we'll do it
again tomorrow and we certainly will
same time same place just catch us
tomorrow see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited